हेलो एवरीवन
एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल
तो प्लीज मुझे यह बता दीजिए सबको मेरी
आवाज सुनाई दे रही है
आई एम ऑडिबल एवरीवन सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई
दे रही
चैट में बता दीजिए।
ओके वेरी गुड इवनिंग ओके ओके ओके थैंक यू
चलो ओके रफीज
गुड इवनिंग एंड एवरीवन अगेन गुड इवनिंग तो
दो मिनट का वेट करते हैं बाकी स्टूडेंट्स
के लिए जिसको ज्वाइन होना है क्लास में तो
तब तक के लिए अगर किसी का कोई भी डाउट है
रिलेटेड टू द प्रीवियस क्लास तो मुझसे पूछ
सकता है। तो अगली दो मिनट में हम क्लास को
स्टार्ट करेंगे। किसी का कोई भी डाउट है
तो वो पूछ सकता है।
किसी का कोई डाउट है?
चलो आज फर्स्ट टाइम कौन आया क्लास में?
पहली क्लास किसकी है? मुझे एक नया नाम
दिखाई दे रहा है। ए के गेमर
ओ टीजीएमएल।
आप लोग फर्स्ट टाइम आए हो क्लास में? आपकी
फर्स्ट टाइम फर्स्ट क्लास है क्या?
ओके निखिल कुमार फर्स्ट टाइम ए जी कुमार
फर्स्ट टाइम ओके इससे पहले कोई भी क्लास
नहीं देखी आप लोगों ने?
कोई भी क्लास इस सीरीज की या जो मैं पढ़ा
रहा हूं कोई भी सिंगल क्लास देखी है
नहीं देखी क्या
ओके फर्स्ट क्लास देखी है।
चलो अच्छी बात है। फर्स्ट क्लास देखी है
तो
ओके कोई नहीं कोई नहीं कोई नहीं। बाकी आप
उसमें शौक वाली प्लेलिस्ट में हो तो कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं। अच्छी बात है। कुछ ना कुछ
सीखते रहो। अगर आप लोग ऑफेंसिव साइड भी
सीखना चाहते हो तो मोस्ट वेलकम। अगर नहीं
सीखना चाहते तो आपकी मर्जी है। चलिए फिर
मुझे लगता नहीं कि स्टूडेंट्स आने वाले
हैं और चलो क्लास को स्टार्ट करते हैं फिर
क्योंकि मुझे एक चीज की श्योरिटी होगी कि
स्टूडेंट्स लाइव नहीं देखते। तो चलो फिर
एक काम करते हैं हम। चलो स्टार्ट करते
हैं। हम टॉपिक स्टार्ट करते हैं। तो मुझे
एक बार बता दीजिए सबको स्क्रीन अच्छे से
दिखाई दे रही है और क्या सभी को मेरी आवाज
सुनाई दे रही है अच्छे से? और अभी हम क्या
करने वाले हैं? अपने टॉपिक को स्टार्ट
करने वाले हैं।
ओके ऑल ओके चलिए फिर जो अभी प्रीवियस
क्लास में मैंने आप लोगों को पढ़ाया था
शायद आप लोगों को समझ में आ गया होगा कुछ
फंडामेंटल्स में हमने कवर किया था कि
एक्चुअल में सोशल इंजीनियरिंग होती क्या
है और
स्टार्टअप किया था हमने सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
का कि सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का जो इंट्रोडक्शन
लिया था कि बहुत सारे सिनेरियो आपको मैंने
कवर किए थे। बहुत सारी चीजें मैंने आप
लोगों के सामने रिप्रेजेंट की थी इन द
फॉर्म ऑफ ए स्लाइड तो शायद वह आप लोगों को
क्लियर हो गई होगी और जो आज फर्स्ट टाइम
क्लास में आए हैं जिसने रिकॉर्डिंग नहीं
देखी है तो प्लीज मैं आप लोगों से
रिक्वेस्ट करूंगा कि प्रीवियस क्लास को
देख लीजिएगा क्योंकि वो इस इस क्लास का
बेस है क्योंकि अगर आप लोगों को
इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए होती है कि मैं जब भी
कोई भी क्लास पब्लिश करता हूं या उसके
शेड्यूल करता हूं उसका जो डिस्क्रिप्शन
होता है ना उसको कंपेयर करके देख लीजिए।
कई बार क्या होता है कि कुछ चीजें टॉपिक
सेकंड क्लास में रिपीटेड रहते हैं। तो
इसका मतलब यह नहीं है कि डिस्क्रिप्शन में
जो मैंने टॉपिक मेंशन किए हैं कि वो टॉपिक
मैं सारे कवर नहीं कर रहा। मैं सारे टॉपिक
कवर करता हूं डिस्क्रिप्शन वाले। बट हो
सकता है कि इस क्लास में टाइम की कमी की
वजह से या किसी भी ऐसी कमी की वजह से वो
टॉपिक रह गए होंगे। तो जिसको हम नेक्स्ट
क्लास में कवर करते हैं। तो उसकी चिंता मत
कीजिए। लेकिन उसको डिस्क्रिप्शन को पढ़
लिया करो कि आपको आईडिया मिल जाएगा कि सर
ने क्या-क्या कवर करने वाले हैं और
क्या-क्या कवर नहीं करने वाले। प्रीवियस
क्लास में आपसे रिलेटेड वो चीज है या नहीं
है। आपके काम की है या नहीं है। तो चलिए
हम स्टार्ट करते हैं सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के
का जो जो हमारा चैप्टर चल रहा था उसको
थोड़ा सा और आगे बढ़ाते हैं और हम बात
करेंगे कि हम कुछ पॉइंट्स पर बात करेंगे।
अभी जो आज के सेशन में हम क्या-क्या
डिस्कस करने वाले हैं? हम डिस्कस करने
वाले हैं कि जो सोशल मीडिया है सोशल
मीडिया का सोशल मीडिया ने जो इस अटैक
वेक्टर को और भी खतरनाक कैसे बनाया या फिर
जो सोशल जो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग है उसकी
हिस्ट्री क्या है या हम बात करें एज ए
मॉडर्न पेंटेस्टर्स आपके लिए सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग सीखनी क्यों जरूरी है और नॉट
द लास्ट
बट लीस्ट कम से कम कि हम एक चीज भी कवर
करने वाले हैं टाइप्स टाइप्स ऑफ सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग कि सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक्स
कितने टाइप्स के होते हैं? तो बेसिकली
हमने क्या बताया? हम चार चीजों पर डिस्कस
करने वाले हैं। चार से पांच सबसे पहली बात
कि जो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का अटैक है उसको
इतना डेंजरस इतना खतरनाक बनाने के लिए
सोशल मीडिया का उसमें क्या रोल है? दूसरा
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग की हिस्ट्री क्या है?
तीसरी चीज हम क्या डिस्कस करेंगे कि एज ए
पेंटेस्टर्स आज के जमाने में एज ए
पेंटेस्टर्स हमें सोशल इंजीनियरिंग सीखने
की क्यों जरूरत है?
हमें क्यों सीखना चाहिए? फोर्थ या फिफ्थ
हम बोल सकते हैं वन टू हां फोर्थ वन हम
सीखेंगे कि टाइप्स ऑफ सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
अटैक। सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक कितने टाइप्स
के होते हैं? तो चलिए फिर हम स्टार्ट करते
हैं सोशल मीडिया जो मॉडर्न प्लेग्राउंड
फॉर सोशल इंजीनियरिंग। देखो आज के जमाने
में अगर कोई भी अटैकर या पेंटेस्टर किसी
के ऊपर साइबर अटैक प्लान कर रहा है या
साइबर अटैक परफॉर्म करना चाहता है तो उसका
सबसे बड़ा वेपन क्या है? उसका सबसे बड़ा
वेपन है उसका आपका सोशल मीडिया। उसका सबसे
बड़ा वेपन क्या है? आपका सोशल मीडिया है।
तो अब जो भी सोशल नेटवर्किंग प्लेटफार्म
है जैसे आपका Lindin है, Facebook है,
Twitter है, Instagram है या YouTube है।
ठीक है? इन प्लेटफार्म के आने से क्या
हुआ? जो अटैकर्स है और जो पेंटेस्टर्स है
उसकी जो कैपेबिलिटी है ना वह बहुत ज्यादा
बढ़ गई। कैसे बढ़ गई? क्योंकि दुनिया के
किसी भी कोने में बैठा हुआ इंसान किसी भी
कंपनी के एंप्लॉय
को डायरेक्टली और ईजीली कांटेक्ट कर सकता
है। आई एम रिपीटिंग अगेन। दुनिया के किसी
भी कोने में बैठा हुआ इंसान या दुनिया के
किसी भी कोने में कोई भी व्यक्ति किसी भी
कंपनी के एंप्लॉय को बहुत को डायरेक्टली
या ईजीली कांटेक्ट कर सकता है। और सबसे
बड़ी बात क्या है? सबसे बड़ी बात क्या है
कि आप किसी भी इंसान की प्रोफाइल देखकर जो
कोई भी यूज़र्स है या कोई भी अह कोई भी
यूज़र्स है उसकी प्रोफाइल देखकर आप क्या कर
सकते हो? तो उसके बारे में बहुत कुछ
बता सकते हो। उसके बारे में बहुत कुछ जान
सकते हो। उसकी सोशल मीडिया प्रोफाइल
देखकर। ठीक है? उसकी सोशल मीडिया प्रोफाइल
देखकर आप क्या-क्या चीजें कर सकते हो? ठीक
है? उसकी सोशल मीडिया प्रोफाइल देखकर आप
क्या कर सकते हो? उसकी जॉब क्या है? काम
क्या करता है? उसका रोल क्या है? किस
कंपनी में काम करता है? कौन सी जगह पर काम
करता है? उसके एक्सपर्टाइज या स्किल क्या
है? कनेक्शन उसका किस-किस के साथ है? या
उसके इंटरेस्ट या उसकी एक्टिविटीज क्या
है? मतलब सोशल मीडिया की पोस्ट देखदेख कर
उसकी जो पर्सनल इंफॉर्मेशन है, पर्सनल
इंसाइट्स के बारे में जान सकते हैं। या वो
किस टाइप का उसका बिहेवियर पैटर्न है, किस
टाइप्स की वो यहां पर चीजें शेयर करता है,
यह सारी चीजें आप क्या कर सकते हो विद दी
हेल्प ऑफ़ सोशल मीडिया आप जान सकते हो। और
सबसे बड़ी दिक्कत क्या है ना कि लोग सोशल
नेटवर्किंग साइट पर जाने या अनजाने में
बहुत सारी प्राइवेट इंफॉर्मेशन भी क्या कर
देते हैं? वो एक्सपोज कर देते हैं। फॉर
एग्जांपल जैसे कॉर्पोरेट ईमेल्स होगी,
उनके फोन नंबर्स होंगे, उनका होम एड्रेसेस
होगा या कंपनी का एड्रेस हो गया। कंपनी का
एड्रेस तो चलो ठीक है कहीं पर भी मिल जाता
है। या फिर उनके प्रोजेक्ट्स की डिटेल
होगी। मतलब कि जो एंप्लॉय है किसी
इंपॉर्टेंट प्रोजेक्ट में काम कर रहा हो
कंपनी के और ऐसे ही जाने अनजाने में उसने
क्या जो करंट ऑनगोइंग प्रोजेक्ट है उसकी
या प्रोजेक्ट कंप्लीट होने के बाद सक्सेस
पार्टी के रूप में उसकी जो इंफॉर्मेशन थी
ऐसे खुशी-खुशी में या कुछ भी लगा लो। उसने
क्या किया? वह इंफॉर्मेशन शेयर कर दी सोशल
मीडिया पर। अब जब वह इंफॉर्मेशन सोशल
मीडिया पर आ गई जब वो इंफॉर्मेशन सोशल
मीडिया पर आ गई तो क्या होगा? एक अटैकर के
लिए वो इंफॉर्मेशन बहुत ज्यादा वैलुएबल हो
जाती है। क्योंकि उसकी हेल्प से क्या करता
है? वो अपने फर्दर अटैक्स प्लान करता है।
फर्दर उसको क्या करना है? उसका नेक्स्ट
स्टेप क्या होगा? क्या प्लानिंग करनी है?
है वह सारी चीज डिसाइड करता है। क्या मुझे
एक चीज बताइए क्या सोशल मीडिया इंटेलिजेंस
ओनली अटैकर्स ही यूज़ करते हैं? जो सोशल
मीडिया इंटेलिजेंस है क्या अटैकर्स ही यूज़
करते हैं?
बताओ सोशल मीडिया इंटेलिजेंस ओनली क्या
अटैकर ही यूज़ करते हैं?
यस या नो?
अगर नहीं तो कौन-कौन यूज करता है? बताओ।
बताओ जो सोशल मीडिया इंटेलिजेंस है या
सोशल मीडिया से इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करना
किसी के बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन निकालना किसी
के बारे में जानना क्या ओनली
हैकर्स या पेंटेस्टर्स ही करते हैं
सब लोग जिंदा हो चैट में सब लोग हो क्लास
में या सो गए क्लास छोड़ के चले गए बताओ
इंटैक्ट करो
समझ में नहीं आ रहा टॉपिक क्या चल रहा है
बताओ टॉपिक नहीं समझ में आ रहा हो सुनाई
नहीं दे रहा हो सवाल समझ में नहीं आया हो
प्लीज बी स्पेसिफिक
यस आंसर नहीं करना चाहते
क्या अटैकर्स ही इसको यूज यूज़ करते हैं
सोशल मीडिया इंटेलिजेंस को या और कोई भी
बताओ जरा
मुझे पता आप लोग नहीं बताओगे। देखिए सोशल
मीडिया से इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करने के लिए
ओनली अटैकर्स ही उसको यूज़ नहीं करता। जो
आपके रिक्रूटर्स होते हैं या उस कंपनी के
जो कंपिटिटर्स होते हैं, वह भी किसी चीज
का यूज करते हैं। आपके साथ कंपटीट करने के
लिए या आपके ऑर्गेनाइजेशन में नीचा दिखाने
के लिए। या फिर जो एडवर्टाइजमेंट कंपनी है
जहां आपके जो मार्केटर्स होते हैं वह भी
सोशल मीडिया इंटेलिजेंस का यूज करते हैं
इंफॉर्मेशन के लिए या जो रिसर्च करते हैं
या जो जर्नलिस्ट हैं वह भी यूज करते हैं।
ओके? नहीं तो जो सिक्योरिटी प्रोफेशनल्स
हैं वो भी यूज करते हैं। मतलब एक अकेला
अटैकर ही इन ऐसा इंसान नहीं है जो सोशल
मीडिया की हेल्प से इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
करता है अपने लिए। नहीं बहुत सारे लोग हैं
डायरेक्टली या इनडायरेक्टली सोशल मीडिया
का यूज़ करते हैं किसी के बारे में जानने
के लिए, इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट करने के लिए या
उसके उस अपने आप को अपडेट करने के लिए।
ओके? बहुत सारे हैं। नाउ अभी हम बात करते
हैं हिस्ट्री ऑफ सोशल इंजीनियरिंग। ए कॉमन
मिसकसेप्शन अमोंग साइबर सिक्योरिटी
बिगिनियर्स इज सोशल इंजीनियरिंग इज ए
कॉनेंपरेरी कॉनेंपरेरी हैकिंग टेक्निक
मतलब क्या है कि बहुत सारे साइबर
सिक्योरिटी प्रोफेशंस को लगता है कि जो
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग है वो एक ऐसी टेक्निक है
जो सिर्फ किसी ऑफेंसिव सिक्योरिटी या
मॉडर्न हैकिंग के साथ आई है। सबको लगता है
कि यह कोई कॉनटेंपरेरी
टेक्निक है जो किसी इसका कलर मैं चेंज कर
लेता हूं अभी के लिए। यह रहा कि कोई
टेंपरेरी हैकिंग जो कौन टेंपरेरी हैकिंग
टेक्निक है जो किसी ऑफेंसिव सिक्योरिटी या
मॉडर्न हैकिंग के साथ आई है। बहुत सारे जो
बिगिनर्स होते हैं ना उनको यह चीज लगती
है। इन रियलिटी सोशल इंजीनियरिंग हैज़ बीन
अराउंड फॉर एज लॉन्ग एज ह्यूमन सोसाइटी
हैज़ एग्जिस्टेड। मतलब लेकिन यह बात
बिल्कुल गलत है। रियलिटी में क्या है कि
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग उतनी ही पुरानी है जितना
कि इंसानी इतिहास
जितने पुराने आप हो जितने पुराने लोग हैं
जो इंसानी इतिहास जितना पुराना है उतनी ही
पुरानी आपकी सोशल इंजीनियरिंग टेक्निक भी
है। थ्रू आउट हिस्ट्री व्हनेवर वैल्यूएबल
इंफॉर्मेशन हैज बीन अवेलेबल देयर हैव
ऑलवेज बीन इंडिविजुअल्स सीकिंग टू एक्वायर
इट थ्रू डिसेप्शन
इनफ्लुएंस मैनपुलेशन और पशुएशन मेरा कहने
का मतलब क्या है? जब से दुनिया में कोई
ऐसी इंफॉर्मेशन एग्जिस्ट करती है जिसको
छुआ कर रखना बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी है या
जिसका
जिसको छुपा कर रखा जाता है या जिसकीेंस
बहुत ज्यादा है तब से उसको निकलवाने
निकलवाने वाले लोग और उसको एक्सप्लइट करने
वाले लोग भी एक्सिस्ट करते हैं। मतलब मतलब
ये है कि दुनिया में जब जब से ऐसी
इंफॉर्मेशन एक्सिस्ट करती है जिसको हाइड
करना जरूरी है तब से उस इंफॉर्मेशन को
एक्सप्लइट करने वाले या उस इंफॉर्मेशन को
निकलवाने वाले भी एकिस्ट करते हैं। इसका
मतलब क्या है? कि इन सोशल इंजीनियरिंग कोई
नई अटैक टेक्निक नहीं है। यह बहुत पहले से
एक्सिस्ट करती है। ओके? यह बहुत पहले से
एग्जिस्ट करती है। इन द पास्ट
डिसेप्शन ओकर थ्रू डायरेक्ट इंटरेक्शन
डिसेप्शन मतलब जो धोखा इंफॉर्मेशन निकाल
निकालने का जो तरीका था मतलब पहले क्या था
वो डायरेक्ट इंटक्शन मतलब फेस टू फेस
कन्वर्सेशन कर ली लेटर्स का यूज कर लिया
फोन कॉल का यूज कर लिया फिजिकल इंपसुएशन
मतलब फिजिकली उस इंफॉर्मेशन को कलेक्ट
किया जाता है आजकल क्या है कि वो
साइकोलॉजिकल टैिक सेम है लेकिन उनको यूज
करने का तरीका बदल गया है जैसे पहले
ज्यादातर क्या था डायरेक्ट इंटरेक्शन करते
थे लेकिन आजकल क्या इनडायरेक्ट हो गया वो
तरीका क्या हो गया सेम तरीका इंफॉर्मेशन
कलेक्ट करने का वाया ईमेल या फेक वेबसाइट
हो गई कोई फेक मैसेजिंग एप्लीकेशनेशंस हो
गई सोशल मीडिया हो गई फोन कॉल्स हो गया या
डिजिटल पर्सना मतलब अभी तो एआई आ गया और
भी ज्यादा चीजें तो कहने का मतलब क्या है
कि सोशल इंजीनियरिंग ने समय समय के
साथ-साथ अपने आप में टेक्निक्स में बदलाव
किया है लेकिन सोशल इंजीनियरिंग कोई नई
टेक्निक नहीं
अभी बात करते हैं दी फ्रेश सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग कैन बी ट्रैक बैक टू डच
इंडस्ट्रलिस्ट जेसी वेनमार्कन हु
इंट्रोड्यूस इट इन 1894
मतलब जो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग टर्म है उसको
सबसे पहले 1894 में डच इंडस्ट्रीज जेसी
वेनमार्कन ने क्रिएट किया था किसने जेसी
वेनमार्कन ने किस में 1894
में इस टर्म को क्या किया था? क्रिएट किया
था। ड्यूरिंग दैट पीरियड द टर्म वाज़ नॉट
रिलेटेड टू साइबर सिक्योरिटी। उस समय क्या
था कि जो टर्म थी यह साइबर सिक्योरिटी से
रिलेटेड नहीं थी। व्हेन मार्कन एडवोकेटेड
फॉर द नीड फॉर स्पेशलिस्ट इन इंडस्ट्रीज।
मतलब व्हेन मार्कन एडवोकेटेड फॉर द नीड
फॉर स्पेशलिस्ट इन इंडस्ट्रीज टू एड्रेस
नॉट ओनली टेक्निकल इश्यूज बट आल्सो ह्यूमन
एंड सोशल चैलेंजेज। मतलब ये इसका मतलब
क्या है कि वेन मार्कन का कहना था कि
इंडस्ट्री में टेक्निकल चैलेंजेस को सॉल्व
करने के साथ-साथ ह्यूमन चैलेंजेस मतलब जो
इंसान की समस्याएं हैं उनको हैंडल करने के
लिए भी स्पेशलिस्ट होने चाहिए। उसका मानना
यह था। वह कह रहे थे कि जो भी टेक्निकल
प्रॉब्लम है उसके साथ-साथ जो इंसानी
प्रॉब्लम्स है उसको सॉल्व करने के लिए भी
कंपनी में इंसान होने चाहिए। इन ए ब्रॉडर
हिस्टोरिकल कॉन्टेक्स्ट सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
परट्स टू द कांसेप्ट ऑफ इन्फ्लुएंसिंग और
ऑर्गेनाइजिंग ह्यूमन बिहेवियर इन ए
सिस्टमेटिक मैनर अकेंड टू हाउ इंजीनियर
इंटैक्ट विद मशीनंस एंड मैकेनिकल
सिस्टम्स। इसका मतलब क्या है कि उस समय उस
पुराने जमाने में जो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग को
डिफाइन किया गया था उसको डिफाइन किया गया
था कि लोगों को इस तरह इनकरेज किया जाए या
इस तरह उनको मोटिवेट किया जाए कि वो अपने
सोशल रिलेशनशिप को बिल्कुल वैसे ही हैंडल
करें जैसे वह किसी मशीन या मैकेनिकल
सिस्टम को अप्रोच करते हैं। आई एम
रिपीटिंग अगेन। लोगों को इस तरह मोटिवेट
किया गया था या उसकी डेफिनेशन लोगों के
सामने ऐसे रिप्रेजेंट की गई थी सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग की कि वह अपनी सोशल रिलेशनशिप
को बिल्कुल वैसे ही हैंडल करें जैसे वो
कंपनी में किसी मशीन या मैकेनिक सिस्टम को
अप्रोच करते हैं। मतलब उनके कहने का मतलब
था कि इंसानी दिमाग को मशीन की तरह
प्रोग्राम किया जाना चाहिए। गेटिंग माय
पॉइंट अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? यहां तक क्लियर
है जो मैं आपको बताने की कोशिश कर रहा
हूं।
यहां तक क्लियर है?
यहां तक क्लियर है? देयर आर टोटल 8 टू
नाइन स्टूडेंट्स प्लीज।
ओके। नेक्स्ट अभी चलते हैं हम। सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग इन मॉडर्न पेट्रेशन टेस्टिंग।
आज के जमाने में सोशल इंजीनियरिंग इन द
पास्ट पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स प्राइमरली कह
कंसंट्रेटेड ऑन टेक्निकल अटैक्स। पहले
टाइम पर मैं बात कर रहा हूं पुराने जमाने
की। इससे पहले जितने भी पेंटेस्टर्स थे वो
क्या करते थे कि जो टेक्निकल अटैक्स थे
उनको फोकस करते थे। टेक्निकल अटैक्स पर
फोकस करते थे। दे एग्जामिन सर्वर्स
नेटवर्क्स, फायरवॉल्स, वेब एप्लीकेशनेशंस,
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स एंड एक्सो सर्विज। वो
क्या करते थे कि जो भी टेक्निकल्स फायर
वाल्स होगी जो भी टेक्निकल सर्वर्स होंगे
उन पर एक्सप्लइट उनको एक्सप्लइट करने में
ज्यादातर ज्यादा फोकस करते थे और सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग को क्या करते थे वो ओवरलुप
करते थे उसको छोड़ देते थे मतलब सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग को कोई वो अटैक नहीं मानते थे
बहुत पहले की बात है इन द पास्ट पुराने
टाइम में टेक्निकल अटैक पे ज्यादा फोकस
किया जाता था रेदर देन सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
अटैक सोशल इंजीनियरिंग को क्या किया जा
किया किया जाने लगा उसको अवॉइड किया जाता
था। उसको ओवरलुक किया जाता था। इन टुडेज़
साइबर सिक्योरिटी लैंडस्केप दिस अप्रोच इज़
इनएट। मतलब आज की बात करें आज की जो भी
साइबर सिक्योरिटी पे टेस्टिंग की बात करें
उसमें आप सोशल इंजीनियरिंग को ओवरलुक नहीं
कर सकते। आप सोशल इंजीनियरिंग को नहीं
छोड़ सकते। ए कंटेंपरेरी
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स मस्ट अंडरस्टैंड द
रियल अटैकर डू नॉट लिमिट देमसेल्व्स टू
प्योरली टेक्निकल मेथड्स। दे विल यूज एनी
मींस नेसेसरी टू अचीव देयर ऑब्जेक्टिव।
मतलब हम बात करें
कि
अगर हम बात करते हैं कि एक कंटेंपरेरी
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर मस्ट अंडरस्टैंड द रियल
अटैकर्स। मतलब कि अगर हम पेन टेस्टिंग की
बात करें जब एक रियल अटैकर्स अपने आपको
अकेले टेक्निकल मेथड तक ही अह बांधकर नहीं
रखता। ओनली वह टेक्निकल मेथड यूज़ नहीं
करता। वो अपने ऑब्जेक्टिव को अचीव करने के
लिए कोई भी तरीका अपनाने के लिए तैयार है।
कोई भी तरीका यूज करने के लिए तैयार है।
चाहे अगर उसको ऐसा लगता है कि एक सर्वर को
ब्रीच करने के लिए एक सर्वर को कंप्रोमाइज
करने के लिए के लिए अगर ह्यूमन बीइंग को
टारगेट करना पड़े तो वो कर लेता है। तो एज
ए पेंटेस्टर एज ए पेंटेस्टर हम क्या करें?
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग तो एज ए पेंटेस्टर हमारी
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है जो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
अटैक है उसको एक वैलिड अटैक वेक्टर की तरह
उसको ओपन उसको यूज किया जाए उसको समझा जाए
और हमें यह मानना चाहिए कि अगर सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग को क्या है कि एक बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट स्किल सेट के रूप में उसको
अपनाया जाए। एज ए पेंटेस्टर हम हमें मानना
है कि जो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक है हमें
भी बिल्कुल उसको एक इंपॉर्टेंट स्किल सेट
के रूप में क्या करना है उसको देखना है या
उसको हमें अडॉप करना है। नेक्स्ट हम बात
करते हैं व्हेन ए मिलिशियस अटैकर एंप्लॉय
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग टैिक्स एथिकल हैकर्स
मस्ट आल्सो गैब्स दिस मेथड टू असिस्ट
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन इन डिफेंडिंग अगेंस्ट देम।
मतलब क्या है कि अगर एक मिलसियस अटैक्टर
इसका यूज कर रहा है तो एज ए पेंटेस्टर एज
ए एथिकल हैकर आप आपको भी इसका यूज़ करना
आना चाहिए। ओके? आपको भी इसका यूज़ करना
आना चाहिए। द गोल इज नॉट टू डिसीव
इंडिविजुअल्स फॉर एम्यूसमेंट बट टू असेस
जेन्युइन सिक्योरिटी प्रिपेयरनेस इन रियल
वर्ल्ड सिनेरियोज़। मतलब क्यों आना चाहिए?
क्योंकि
आप जिस कंपनी के लिए काम कर रहे हो या आप
जिस कंपनी को यह दिखाना चाहते हो या जिस
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर को आप पेन टेस्टिंग कर
रहे हो तो इट इज योर रिस्पांसिबिलिटी कि
यह फाइंड आउट करना कि उसकी सिक्योरिटी
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर में एक्चुअल गैप्स कहां
पर है। अगर ड्यूरिंग पेन टेस्टिंग
आप सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक्स टेस्ट नहीं
करते तो इसका मतलब यह है कि जब आप अपनी
फाइनल रिपोर्ट सबमिट करोगे कंपनी को तो
उसका जो सिक्योरिटी रिस्क है उसका आप
एक्यूरेट आईडिया नहीं दे पाओगे। आपने क्या
किया? उनकी फिजिकल सर्वर्स को टेस्ट कर
लिया। उनके इंटरनल नेटवर्क को टेस्ट कर
लिया। व्हाट अबाउट ह्यूमन बिहेवियर? आपने
उसको टेस्ट नहीं किया और जब तक वह टेस्ट
नहीं हुआ तो आप एग्जैक्ट रिस्क की रिपोर्ट
नहीं दे सकते क्योंकि यह भी उतना ही
इंपॉर्टेंट अटैक है जितना बाकी अटैक्स है
और यह चीज आपको डिस्क्राइब करनी है जब आप
एज ए पेंटेस्टर किसी कंपनी में काम करो तो
आपको बेस्ट बनना है। आपको चीजें समझानी है
अथॉरिटी को कि हमें यह भी ट्राई करना
चाहिए। अब यह ट्राई करने का यह मतलब नहीं
कि किसी इंसान के प्रति आप उसको
शर्मिंदा करना चाहते हो किसी को
इंडिविजुअल को टारगेट करने के लिए नहीं आप
उस कंपनी को रियल वर्ल्ड सिनेरियो के साथ
क्या करवाने के लिए अवेयरनेस करवाने के
लिए रियल वर्ल्ड चैलेंजेस के साथ उसको
सिक्योरिटी प्रोवाइड करने के लिए यह आपकी
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है। नाउ
यह कुछ चीजें हैं कि इस असेसमेंट में हमें
क्या-क्या चीजों के बारे में पता चलता है।
यह कुछ शायद आपको क्लियर करने मतलब हमें
यह पता चलता है कि एंप्लयर ट्रस्ट मतलब जो
एंप्लाइजज़ हैं वह किसी अनफिलियर
कम्युनिकेशंस पे तो ट्रस्ट नहीं कर रहे
हैं या किस वेदर एंप्लयर टेक टाइम या फिर
क्या कर रहा है कि जो अनयूजुअल रिक्वेस्ट
आती है एंप्लई उसको रिसोंड करने में कितना
समय ले रहा है हम इसमें यह टेस्ट करते हैं
जो सिक्योरिटी अवेयरनेस ट्रेनिंग कितनी है
एंप्लई को या फेसिंग से कितने जो सिस्टम्स
हैं वह फेसिंग से अपने आप को बचाने के लिए
कौन-कौन से मेजर्स यूज़ कर रहे हैं या
एंप्लई कितनी सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन एक्सपोज
कर पा रहा है पब्लिकली या यह चीज पता करने
के लिए कि वो अंडर प्रेशर या अर्जेंट
सिचुएशन में कैसे रिएक्ट करेगा एक एंप्लई
या फिर हम यह बताने के लिए कि जो उनकी
फिजिकल सिक्योरिटी के जो प्रोटोकॉल्स हैं
उनकी कितनी नॉलेज है उनके एंप्लाइजज़ को या
वो कितनी ट्रेनिंग प्रोवाइड कर रहे हैं
अपने एंप्लॉय को। यह सारी चीजें क्या है
आप ड्यूरिंग सोशल इंजीनियरिंग रिपोर्ट में
बताते हो। को इतनी सारी चीजें आप चेक करते
हो एक सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक के अंदर। नाउ
अभी हम बात करते हैं एक फेसिंग सिमुलेशन
इन सिक्योरिटी असेसमेंट। मेरे कह कहने का
मतलब क्या है? इसमें इसका मतलब है कि
पेंटेस्टिंग और रेड टीमिंग एक्सरसाइज के
दौरान आप क्या करते हो? आप फिशिंग
सिमुलेशन करवाते हो। मतलब अगर आपसे कोई
सजेशन मांगे या आपसे कोई पूछे तो हमें
क्या करना चाहिए कि सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के
लिए तो आपका सजेशन होना चाहिए सर या डियर
मैम डियर सर या जो भी है अथॉरिटी है कि
हमें क्या करना है कि फिशिंग सिमुलेशन
करना चाहिए यह जानने के लिए कि उनके जो
एंप्लाइजज़ हैं वह कितने वनेबल है। उस
कंपनी के एंप्लाइजज़ कितने वनेबल्स हैं।
उनको कितनी सिक्योरिटी अवेयरनेस अवेयरनेस
है और जो भी कंट्रोल्स हैं उनमें
कहां-कहां पर इंप्रूवमेंट की ज़रूरत है।
कंपनी के अंदर जितने भी सिस्टम्स लगे हुए
हैं उनमें कहां-कहां पर हमें पॉलिसीज या
इंप्रूवमेंट करने की जरूरत है। यही होता
है आपका एक फेसिंग सिमुलेशन। और मैं आपको
जिस चीज की बता रहा हूं क्योंकि सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग जब अटैक टेस्ट किया जाएगा
उसमें आप क्या करते हो? फिशिंग सिमुलेशन
का ही यूज़ कर देते हो। ऑब्जेक्टिव क्या
होता है? यह जानना कि कितने लोग सस्फिशियस
लिंक पर क्लिक कर रहे हैं। कितने लोग
अनएक्सेक्टेड अटैचमेंट को ओपन कर रहे हैं।
कितने लोग क्रेडेंशियल्स को सबमिट कर रहे
हैं? कितने लोग उस इंसिडेंट को रिपोर्ट कर
रहे हैं सिक्योरिटी टीम को? इससे आपको
बहुत सारे सवालों का जवाब मिलता है। सवाल
कौन-कौन से जवाब क्या-क्या मिलता है कि
कितने लोग ऐसी चीजों के बारे में अवेयर
हैं। मतलब अवेयरनेस कितनी है लोगों के
अंदर? ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के जो एंप्लाइज हैं
उनके अंदर कितनी अवेयरनेस है यह जानने के
लिए हम क्या करते हैं? फेसिंग सिमुलेशन
अटैक परफॉर्म करते हैं। वो भी विद प्रॉपर
ऑथराइजेशन विद प्रॉपर
अथॉरिटी के साथ। नेक्स्ट अब बात करते हैं
टाइप्स ऑफ सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक्स। अब
बात करते हैं हम टाइप्स ऑफ सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग अटैक्स। किसकी बात कर रहे हैं
हम? टाइप्स ऑफ सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक्स।
यह कुछ टाइप्स के सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक्स
हैं। तो, एक सक्सेसफुल
सोशल इंजीनियर पेंटेस्टर्स बनने के लिए
आपको
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट
कंपोनेंट्स होते हैं या कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट
अटैक वेक्टर टाइप्स होते हैं जिनके बारे
में आपको पता होना चाहिए। और उसकी अच्छी
खासी आपको नॉलेज होनी चाहिए और जरूरत
पड़ने पर आपको वह यूज़ करने आने चाहिए। वो
कौन-कौन से हैं आपको? डमस्टर ड्राइविंग,
विसिंग, फिशिंग,
स्मिसिंग,
उसके बाद बेटिंग, स्पेयर फिशिंग,
प्रीटेक्स्टिंग, टेल गेटिंग, वेलिंग। यह
कुछ टाइप्स के फेसिंग अटैक्स होते हैं। दी
आर द मोस्ट कॉमन मोस्ट पॉपुलर फिशिंग
फिसिंग अटैक्स जो ज्यादातर यूज किए जाते
हैं। तो इनको हम एक काम करते हैं वन बाय
वन बिल्कुल प्यार से आराम से एक-एक करके
समझने की कोशिश करते हैं कि कौन सा अटैक
किस चीज से जुड़ा है? उस अटैक का मतलब
क्या होता है? वो कैसे परफॉर्म किया जाता
है? यह सारी चीजें हम एक-एक करके देखने
वाले हैं। नेक्स्ट सबसे पहला अटैक होता है
हमारा प्री टेक्स्टिंग मतलब बिल्डिंग ए
ब्लू एबल बिलीवेबल आइडेंटिटी। प्री
टेक्स्टिंग इनवॉल्व्स क्राफ्टिंग ए फेक
आइडेंटिटी रोल सिनेरियो टू एस्टैब्लिश
ट्रस्ट विद ए टारगेट इन अदर वर्ड्स द
अटैकर्स स्पिन ए कन्वेंसिंग नैरेटिव टू
डिसीव्यू। अगर हम बात करें कि सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग फ्रेमवर्क के मुताबिक प्री
टेक्स्टिंग का मतलब होता है इंपशनेटिंग
समवन यानी कि किसी भी इंसान की या किसी भी
अथॉरिटी की या किसी भी चीज की झूठी
आइडेंटिटी अडॉप करना। झूठी आइडेंटिटी को
धारण करना। इसमें आप क्या करते हो? एक बैक
स्टोरी एक बैक स्टोरी स्टोरी क्रिएट करते
हो। ठीक है? एक बैक स्टोरी क्या करते हो?
क्रिएट करते हो। मतलब एक पूरी तरह से
बिल्कुल फेक कैरेक्टर प्ले करते हो। एक
फेक स्टोरी आप क्रिएट करते हो टारगेट
टारगेट से कांटेक्ट करने के लिए। ठीक है?
टारगेट से कांटेक्ट करने के लिए और टारगेट
से वह इंफॉर्मेशन निकालने के लिए या एक
ऐसा सॉलिड रीजन तैयार करते हो ताकि आपका
जो टारगेट है उसके साथ आपका कांटेक्ट
बिल्ड हो। एंड उसको जब आप एक फेक रोल प्ले
करते हो, एक फेक सिनेरियो सेटअप करते हो
या आप एक ऐसी एक स्टोरी तैयार करते हो
ताकि जो आपका टारगेट है आपसे कांटेक्ट करे
आपके साथ जुड़े आपके साथ एस्टैब्लिश करे उस
चीज को हम क्या बोलते हैं कॉन्टेक्स्ट फॉर
कांटेक्ट
कांटेक्ट फॉर कांटेक्ट उसको हम क्या बोलते
हैं कॉन्टेक्स्ट फॉर कांटेक्ट
फॉर इंस्टेंस एन इंडिविजुअल माइट
इंपर्सनेट समवन अब यह कैसे-कैसे कर सकते
हो आप क्या कर सकते हो एक फेक आईटी
स्पोर्ट इंजीनियर बन सकते हो आईटी स्पोर्ट
या कोई ह्यूमन रिसोर्सेज
डिपार्टमेंट
फेक ह्यूमन रिसोर्सेज डिपार्टमेंट आप क्या
कर सकते हो
का उसका एक मेंबर बन सकते हो ऑफिसर बन
सकते हो या कोई डिलीवरी सर्विस बनकर आप
उनको कॉल कर सकते हो उनको प्रीक्स्ट कर
सकते हो कोई वेंडर बनके प्रीटेक्स्ट कर
सकते हो कोई सिक्योरिटी टीम बनके
प्रीटेक्स्ट कर सकते हो मेंटेनेंस
एक्टिविटी या मेंटेनेंस कंपनी मतलब यह
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको कहां से मिलेगी
सोशल सोशल
मीडिया से ठीक है या आपको कहां से मिलेगी
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग करके या फिर आपका यह
सारा क्या है इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग का पार्ट
है और यह रोल आप तभी प्रिटेक्स्ट कर पाओगे
जब आपको पता होगा कि कंपनी में कौन क्या
कैसे क्या रोल है कंपनी किसके साथ थर्ड
पार्टी के साथ डील करती है किसके साथ यह
सारी चीजें डील करती है तब जाके आप क्या
कर सकते हो एक अपना सॉलिड प्रीक्स्ट
क्रिएट कर सकते हो फॉर एग्जांपल एक
एग्जांपल लेते हैं देखो पावर ऑफ प्री
टेक्स्टिंग मैं आपको क्या है कि एक प्री
टेक्स्टिंग की पावर पावर दिखाता हूं। फॉर
एग्जांपल मान लो आपने क्या किया? एक
क्लिपबोर्ड लिया। आपने हाथ में एक
क्लिपबोर्ड लेके खड़े हो गए। और आपने क्या
किया? एक डमस्टर मैनेजमेंट कंपनी की
यूनिफार्म पहन ली। यह डमस्टर मैनेजमेंट की
कंपनी की यूनिफार्म पहन ली। एक आई कार्ड
रख लिया। ठीक है? हाथ में ग्लव्स पहन लिए।
बिल्कुल प्रोफेशनल बनने के लिए। हाथ में
एक क्या कर लिया? क्लिपबॉर्ड ले लिया। और
एक कंपनी है उस कंपनी के कंपनी का जो ऑफिस
है उसके बाहर जाकर आप खड़े हो गए और आपने
कहा कि आप चेकिंग के लिए आए हो। आपने कहा
आप चेकिंग के लिए आए हो। अब ऐसे केस में
एक बात बताओ क्या वह कंपनी शक भी कर
पाएगी? नहीं कर पाएगी। बिकॉज़ आपका
प्रीक्स्ट ही इतना स्ट्रांग है। क्योंकि
हाथ में क्लेबोर्ड है। आईडी कार्ड देखो
आपकी जो प्रेजेंस क्या है? यूनिफार्म भी
पहनी है। आईडी बैच भी है। प्रोफेशनल आपका
बिहेवियर है। उसके बाद क्या है?
आजकल
आपने क्या बोला कि आप एक रूटीन वेस्ट
मैनेजमेंट इंस्पेक्शन के लिए आए हो
क्योंकि ये चीज आपको पता होनी चाहिए कि
कौन क्या चीज कब होती है विदाउट
इंफॉर्मेशन यू कैन नॉट डू तो ये सारी चीज
होने के बाद क्या है कि अथॉरिटी आप पे शक
नहीं कर रही आपके साथ सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
शेयर कर देगी इंफॉर्मेशन शेयर करने का
मतलब आपका पर्पज क्या हो सकता है देखो आप
एक किसी कंपनी में आए ठीक है आप कंपनी में
आए डमस्टर मैनेजमेंट बनके तो आप क्या
करोगे करोगे फिजिकल एक्सेस के लिए आए हो
आप उनके ऑफिस में घूमोगे देखोगे हर एक
ऑफिस में जाओगे वहां से थोड़ी-थोड़ी आप
इधर-उधर नजर देखते रहोगे और आपको पता है
कि आपको पता चल जाएगा कि कौन सा ऑफिस कहां
पर है सर्वर रूम कहां है कि किसी सिस्टम
को देखकर एंप्लई काम कर रहे होंगे वहां
आपको पता चल जाएगा कि कौन सा सॉफ्टवेयर
यूज़ हो रहा है। किसी सॉफ्टवेयर ज्यादा
काम कर रहे हैं। कौन क्या एंप्लॉय है मतलब
वहां पर आप देख के बहुत सारी चीजों के
बारे में अवेयर हो सकते हो। बहुत सारी
चीजें की इंफॉर्मेशन आप लेके जा सकते हो।
बिना कुछ बोले, बिना कुछ पूछे। बिना कुछ
बोले, बिना कुछ पूछे आप क्या करो?
घूमते-घूमते सारी चीजें देख सकते हो। कहां
पर क्या चीज
सही है, कहां पर क्या चीज सही नहीं है।
कहां आपका काम हो सकता है और कहां पर आपका
काम नहीं हो सकता। ठीक है? मतलब किसी
सिस्टम को देख के, किसी सर्वर को देख के,
किसी
ऐसी चीज को देख के आप आईडिया लगा सकते हो
कि ओके यहां पर यह चीज डील हो रही होगी।
यहां पर यह चीज डील हो रही होगी।
यहां पर ये चीज क्या हो रही होगी? डील हो
रही होगी।
व्हाट हैपन गाइस?
साइलेंट लवर। व्हाट हैपन? क्या हुआ? कोई
इशू हुआ?
चैट में कोई कुछ बोल रहा है। लाइव वीडियो
पर भी वी ऐड
ऐसा है क्या?
नहीं यार ऐसा तो मे भी बताओ थोड़ा सा ऐसा
है क्या कुछ?
तो यहां तक सबको क्लियर है चीजें?
यहां तक सबको क्लियर है?
समझ में आ गया? प्री टेक्स्टिंग क्या होता
है? बाकी तो हम और भी सीखेंगे इसके बारे
में। बट यहां तक चीजें समझ में आ गई। प्री
टेक्स्टिंग क्या होता है? और पावर ऑफ प्री
टेक्स्टिंग अगर आपका
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] प्री टेक्स्ट
सॉलिड है तो आप पर कोई भी शक नहीं कर
सकता।
ओके। नेक्स्ट अभी आते हैं हम फेसिंग अटैक
के ऊपर। अब आते हैं हम किसके ऊपर? फेसिंग
अटैक के ऊपर। अब फेसिंग अटैक क्या है
आपका? सबसे कॉमन और डेंजरस अटैक वेक्टर
है। सबसे कॉमन और सबसे डेंजरस अटैक वेक्टर
में से एक अटैक वेक्टर है। कौन सा आपका?
फेसिंग अटैक। फेसिंग स्टैंड्स आउट एज वन
ऑफ द मोस्ट कॉमन फॉर्म ऑफ सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग अटैक। इट इनवॉल्व्स सेंडिंग
डिसेप्टिव ईमेल्स मैसेजेस लिंक्स डिजाइन
टू मिसलीड यूजर्स इनू टेकिंग अनसेफ एक्शन
मतलब क्या है कि फिशिंग बेसिकली
फेक ईमेल भेजने का एक प्रोसेस है जिससे
टारगेट को फोर्स या इन्फ्लुएंस किया जा
सके ताकि क्या-क्या एक्शन परफॉर्म करें वो
किसी एक लिंक पर क्लिक करें किसी अटैचमेंट
को ओपन करें किसी फाइल को डाउनलोड करें या
फिर वेबसाइट पर क्रेडेंशियल
क्या करें? एंटर करें या फिर कोई लॉगिन
प्र्ट को अप्रूव करें। किसी क्यूआर कोड को
स्कैन करे या फिर कोई सेंसिटिव इनेशन शेयर
करें। फेसिंग का मतलब क्या है? कि एक ऐसी
प्रोसेस, एक ऐसी झूठी प्रोसेस, ऐसी फेक
प्रोसेस या फेक ईमेल भेजना जिससे अटैक
जिसमें प्र किया जाए, टारगेट को पोर्स
किया जाए, इन्फ्लुएंस किया जाए। यह सारे
एक्शन यह सारे काम करने के लिए कौन से यह
सारे काम करने के लिए उसको क्या किया जाए
फोर्स किया जाए या उसको इनफ्लुएंस किया
जाए उसको मैनपुलेट किया जाए वो होता है
आपका फिशिंग अटैक क्या होता है आपका
फिशिंग अटैक अभी आते हैं हम एक कन्वेंशनल
फिशिंग अटैक किस पे आते हैं हम एक
कन्वेंशनल फिशिंग अटैक अब कन्वेंशनल
फिशिंग क्या होता है यह एक सिंपल टर्म है
एक जेनेरिक टर्म है मतलब क्या है कि इसमें
किसी स्पेसिफिक पर्सन को टारगेट नहीं किया
जाता। इसमें किसी एक स्पेसिफिक व्यक्ति को
टारगेट नहीं किया जाता। इसमें साइबर
क्रिमिनल्स क्या करते हैं? साइबर
क्रिमिनल्स बड़े-बड़े ईमेल्स की लिस्ट बाय
करते हैं। चाहे वो डार्क नेट से करते हो,
डार्क वेब से करते हो, चाहे वो जो डाटा
आपके एक्सपोज होते हैं, उनसे उनका क्या
करते हैं? वह बड़े-बड़े ईमेल एड्रेसेस की
लिस्ट को बाय करते हैं। फिर क्या करते
हैं? वह मास ईमेल भेज देते हैं। मास ईमेल
कैंपेन करते हैं। मतलब उन सभी ईमेल एड्रेस
पर एक फेसिंग ईमेल भेज देंगे। क्या कर
देंगे? उन सभी ईमेल एड्रेस पर एक फेसिंग
ईमेल भेज देंगे। और उस ईमेल को ऐसे बनाया
जाता है जहां या तो कोई लॉगिन करवाया
जाएगा किसी फेक वेबसाइट पर या फिर हम बात
करें कि कोई फाइल डाउनलोड की करवाया जाए।
कोई अटैचमेंट ओपन करवाया जाएगा। उसके बाद
वेट किया जाता है कि कोई क्या करें? उस
फाइल को ओपन करें और जैसे ही उस फाइल को
कोई ओपन करेगा हैकर के पास या उस अटैकर के
पास उसका रिमोट एक्सेस मिल जाएगा और जब
किसी के पास उसका सेल एक्सेस मिल गया
रिमोट एक्सेस मिल गया तो आप सबको पता है
उसके बाद क्या है पोस्ट एक्सप्लटेशन अटैक
परफॉर्म होगा या प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
परफॉर्म होगा तो कन्वेंशनल फिशिंग का मतलब
यह है कि
इसमें जितने भी ईमेल एड्रेसेस हैं या उस
कंपनी की जितनी भी ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन है
मस या जितने भी एंप्लाइजज़ हैं सभी के पास
क्या है कि एक साथ ईमेल भेज दिया जाता है
और उस टाइम का वेट किया जाता है कोई ना
कोई उस पे क्लिक करे कोई ना कोई उसको
क्लिक करने के बाद
उस पे रिएक्ट करें उस पे रिएक्ट करे
ओके उसको रिएक्ट करें अब इसकी प्रोसेस
क्या होती है नॉर्मली कि एक कन्वेंशनल
फिशिंग ईमेल कैसे काम करता है पहले एक
लिस्ट तैयार की जाती है पब्लिक सोर्सेस से
डाटा ब्रीचेस से सोशल मीडिया से कंपनी
वेबसाइट से डार्क वेब से फॉर एग्जांपल
इसमें कुछ 10,000 कुछ 10 लाख या 10
मिलियंस की उसकी लिस्ट है। उसके बाद एक
मास कैंपेन प्लान किया जाता है। मतलब एक
ऐसी फेक एसएमएस फेक ईमेल रेडी किया जाएगा
और उसको एक साथ किया जाएगा। सबको भेज दिया
जाएगा। स्टेप थ्री में थाउजेंड्स ऑफ
रेसिपिएंट्स होंगे या जो मिलियंस ऑफ
रेसिपिएंट्स हैं उनको एक साथ भेज दिया
जाएगा। उसके बाद वेट किया जाता है कौन उस
पे क्लिक कर रहा है कौन उस पे साइन इन कर
रहा है कौन क्या कर रहा है और जैसे ही कोई
भी उसके साथ इंटैक्ट करेगा इंटैक्ट करते
उसका सेल एक्सेस उसको मिल जाएगा और वह फिर
क्या करेगा उसके ऊपर फर्दर एक्शन परफॉर्म
करेगा या फिर कंपनी इसको परफॉर्म करवा रही
है तो अपनी रिपोर्ट में लिख देगा कि इतने
लोगों ने क्लिक किया इतने लोगों ने फाइल
डाउनलोड की इतने लोगों को क्रेडेंशियल मिल
गए इतना यह एट्रक्ट यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
मिल गई
हां निखिल कुमार उसको डिटेक्ट भी किया जा
सकता है। उसको ब्लॉक भी किया जा सकता है।
उसको आइडेंटिफाई भी किया जा सकता है शॉक
टीम के द्वारा।
ठीक है?
उसके बाद हम बात करते हैं कि एक एक रियल
डाटा पर नजर डालते हैं। रियल डाटा में आप
देखोगे जो एक्सप्लइट किट का नाम सुना है
सबने? एक्सप्लइट किट क्या होती है?
एक्सप्लइट किट किसको पता है कि एक्सप्लइट
किट होता क्या है?
एक्सप्लइट किट क्या होता है?
बताओ।
देखिए निखिल कुमार आप पूछ रहे हो कि सर
कैसे तो अभी वह आज के कांसेप्ट का पार्ट
नहीं है। फिर कभी बता दूंगा मैं क्योंकि
यह शॉक का पार्ट है। शॉक में पढ़ाया जाना
चाहिए। यह
देखो एक्सप्लॉयड किट क्या होते हैं? वह
ऐसे सॉफ्टवेयर्स होते हैं या ऐसे
प्रोग्राम्स होते हैं जिनका यूज़ क्या
किया जाता है? मालवेयर को ड्रॉप करने के
लिए यूज किया जाता है। मालवेयर को ड्रॉप
करने के लिए किसी सिस्टम के ऊपर मालवेयर
को ड्रॉप करने के लिए यूज किया जाता है।
उनको बोलते हैं एक्सप्लइट किट। और
एक्सप्लइट किट का सबसे ज्यादातर यूज़ किया
जाता है किसके अंदर? फिशिंग कैंपेन में।
एक्सप्लइट किट का क्या ज्यादातर किसके
अंदर यूज़ किया जाता है? फिशिंग कैंपेन में
ज्यादातर यूज़ किया जाता है एक्सप्लइट किट
का। ताकि जो सिस्टम है वह मालवे से
इनफेक्टेड हो जाए या फिर आपका जो काम उसे
करवाना है वह खो जाए। दूसरा हम बात करें
अकॉर्डिंग टू सीमेंटिक
जो सीमेंटिक माइक्रोसॉफ्ट सीमेंट है उसकी
रिपोर्ट के मुताबिक इंटरनेट पर जितने भी
यूआरएल्स हैं जितने भी यूआरएल्स हैं उनमें
से 0.5% कितने
5%
0.5%
फिशिंग ट्रैफिक होता है। कौन सा ट्रैफिक
होता है? फिशिंग ट्रैफिक होगा। मतलब हम कह
सकते हैं कि
फॉर एग्जांपल अगर 224 टोटल यूआरएल स्कैन
हो रहे हैं तो 224 में से हर एक यूआरएल एक
फिशिंग कैंपेन होगा। एक फिशिंग यूआरएल
होता है। 224 में से एक यूआरएल फिशिंग
यूआरएल होता है। यह डाटा मैं अपने पास से
नहीं बोल रहा। सीमेंटिक है उसका डाटा यह
बोल रहा है। मैंने अपने पास से उसमें कुछ
भी नहीं बोला। सीमेंटिंग का डाटा इस चीज
को बोल रहा है कि इंटरनेट पर जितना भी
ट्रैफिक ट्रैवल करता है उसमें 0.5% यूआरएल
फिशिंग ट्रैफिक होता है। या हम बोल सकते
हैं हर एक 224 यूआरएल में से एक यूआरएल
मिलशियस होता है। गेटिंग माय पॉइंट? सबको
समझ में आया कि हम आपको क्या बताने की
कोशिश कर रहे हैं?
समझ में आ गया?
यह एक रियल वर्ल्ड डाटा है।
मैं अपने पास से कुछ भी नहीं बता रहा।
सर्च करोगे मिल जाएगा।
ओके। नेक्स्ट अब आते हैं हम स्पीयर
फेसिंग। किसके ऊपर आते हैं हम? स्पीयर
फेसिंग अटैक के ऊपर। स्पीयर फेसिंग।
कौन सा? टारगेट अटैक के बाद में।
तो स्पीयर फेसिंग पढ़ने से पहले एक चीज
समझते हैं। आपने अभी कन्वेंशनल फेसिंग के
बारे में पढ़ा था। किसके बारे में पढ़ा
था? अभी आपने कन्वेंशनल फेसिंग अटैक के
बारे में पढ़ा था। तो क्या हम कन्वेंशनल
फेसिंग अटैक में क्या कर रहे थे? मास ईमेल
कैंपेन परफॉर्म कर रहे थे। मतलब हम क्या
कर रहे थे? एक समुंदर में बहुत बड़ा जाल
फेंक रहे थे। ठीक है? जाल का मतलब हम बहुत
सारी ईमेल्स एक साथ सबको भेज रहे थे। ठीक
है? एक साथ हमने क्या कर दिया? बहुत सारी
ईमेल सबको भेज दी और वेट कर रहे थे उस जाल
में फंसने का कि उस जाल में कितने लोग
फसेंगे। यह थी आपकी कन्वेंशनल फेसिंग।
वहीं पर स्पीयर फिशिंग क्या होती है? वहीं
पर स्पीयर फेसिंग इसके बिल्कुल अलग होती
है। स्पीयर फेसिंग को आप ऐसे बोल सकते हो।
एक ऐसा मछुआरा जो क्या कर रहा है? जाल
फेंकने की बजाय पूरा नेट फने फेंकने की
बजाय वह क्या कर रहा है? भाला ले खड़ा है।
वह क्या कर रहा है? एक भाला ले खड़ा है।
एक भाला ले खड़ा है। और जैसे ही निशाना
मिलेगा भाले से उसको अटैक कर देगा। उस
मछली को पकड़ लेगा। बट इस चीज के लिए भी
उस मछुआरे को दो चीजें की नॉलेज होनी
चाहिए। दो चीजों पर उसकी रिसर्च होनी
चाहिए या दो चीजें हैं उसके बारे में उसको
पता होना चाहिए। पहली बात उसको यह पता
होना चाहिए कि जो मछली है उसका बिहेवियर
क्या है? उसका पैटर्न क्या है? बाहर
निकलने का कब कब वो बाहर निकलेगी? कब बाहर
नहीं निकलती? कब इधर रहती है? नहीं रहती।
मतलब कितनी मछलियां इधर आती हैं? कितनी
नहीं आती? या पर्टिकुलर वैरायटी को आप
पकड़ रहे हो तो कब कब आती है? किस सीजन
में आती है? लो वाटर में या हाई वाटर में
बहुत सारी चीजें रिसर्च करने के बाद वो
क्या करता है? एक भाला लेके खड़ा रहता है
और जैसे ही वो उसके सामने आएगी उसको मार
के वो पकड़ लेगा। सेम स्पेयर फेसिंग में
भी क्या होता है? कोई भी एक सोशल इंजीनियर
स्पेयर फेसिंग में क्या करता है? अपने
टारगेट को टारगेट कंपनी के बारे में क्या
करता है? सबसे पहले ओसेंट कलेक्शन करता
है। क्या करता है? ओसेंट थोड़ा यहां दिख
नहीं रहा होगा टारगेट कंपनी के बारे में
वह क्या करता है ओसेंट कलेक्शन करता है
ठीक है ओसेंट
ज्यादा से ज्यादा ओसेंट इकट्ठा करता है
उसके बाद उसको सिंथेसाइज करता है फिल्टर
करता है और रियल नॉन रियल इंफॉर्मेशन को
अलग-अलग कर लेता है एक्यूरेट जो 100%
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन है उसके साथ क्या करता है
वह अपना हथियार तैयार करता है उसको
वेपनाइज करता है ठीक है उसको वेपनाइज करता
है फिर उसको को क्या कर देता है? उस
पर्टिकुलर टारगेट उस पर्टिकुलर इंसान या
उस पर्टिकुलर प्रोफाइल उस पर्टिकुलर
इंडिविजुअल को क्या करता है? उसके पास
भेजता है। और इससे क्या होता है? उसकी जो
एक्यूरेसी है
अगर इसकी एक्यूरेसी सक्सेस रेट अगर इसकी
2% है मान के चलें।
तो उसकी एक्यूरेसी वहीं पर 20% हो जाती
है। वहीं पर उसकी एक्यूरेसी 20% बढ़ जाती
है। बिकॉज़ उसने रिसर्च की है और बिल्कुल
वो निशाना लगा के बैठा हुआ है। तो दैट इज
द डिफरेंस बिटवीन कन्वेंशनल फिशिंग एंड ए
स्पीयर फेसिंग। समझ में आ गई?
तो नेक्स्ट स्पेयर फिशिंग इज मोर प्रिसाइज
एंड टारगेटेड वेरिएशन ऑफ फिशिंग। बिल्कुल
यह बहुत ज्यादा प्रिसाइज और टारगेटेड
वेरिएशंस है फिशिंग का। अनलाइक ट्रेडिशनल
फिशिंग व्हिच इज सेंट इनडिसिमेंटली
टू थाउजेंड ऑफ इंडिविजुअल्स स्पेयर फिशिंग
इज मिटिक्यूसली क्राफ्टेड फॉर ए पर्टिकुलर
पर्सन, टीम, डिपार्टमेंट और ऑर्गेनाइजेशन।
इसका कहने का मतलब क्या है? कि हजारों
लोगों के पास इंडिविजुअल मेल भेजने की
बजाय स्पेयर फिशिंग क्या करता है?
पर्टिकुलर जो पर्सन है या जो पर्टिकुलर
डिपार्टमेंट है जो पर्टिकुलर टीम है या
पर्टिकुलर ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस को ही टारगेट
करते हैं। एंड द अटैकर बिगिंस बाय और यह
अटैकर कैसे कर पाते हैं? पहले वो क्या
करते हैं? ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस परफॉर्म
करते हैं। उस टारगेट के बारे में, उनके
रोल के बारे में, उनका जो कम्युनिकेशन
स्टाइल कैसा है? कैसे वह काम करते हैं?
कहां-कहां जाते हैं, क्या-क्या करते हैं?
और क्या-क्या नहीं करते वह सारी चीजें वह
इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट करते हैं। उसके बाद
क्या करते हैं? वह अपना स्पेयर फेसिंग
अटैक परफॉर्म करते हैं। एंड स्पेयर फेसिंग
इज फ्रीक्वेंटली एंप्लॉयड बाय साइबर
क्रिमिनल ऑर्गेन फ्रीक्वेंटली किसके बाद
दोबारा यूज़ किया जाता है? या तो इसको
साइबर क्रिमिनल ऑर्गेनाइजेशन यूज़ करती
हैं। या जो एपीटीज हैं एपीटीज का नाम सुना
होगा। एडवांस पर्सिस्टेंट थ्रेट एपीटी
ग्रुप्स होते हैं। ठीक है? माइटर अटैक
फ्रेमवर्क के ऊपर आपको पता चल जाएगा। वह
यूज़ करते हैं या फिर कुछ हैकर्स अटैकर्स
मिलके स्पेयर फेसिंग परफॉर्म करते हैं।
ठीक है? और जिसके क्या होता है? हायर
सक्सेस रेट होती है कंपेयर टू द आपकी
कन्वेंशनल फेसिंग अटैक। एंड क्लाइंट
फ्रीक्वेंटली इन्वेस्ट इन स्पेयर फेसिंग
असेसमेंट टू डिटरमाइन इफ देयर एंप्लई कैन
रिकॉग्नाइज रियलिस्टिक एंड टारगेट अटैक।
और जो कोई भी आजकल जो भी कंपनी है ठीक है?
या आप किसी कंपनी में एज ए सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग काम कर रहे हो या आप एज ए
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के कंसलटेंट के रूप में
काम कर रहे हो तो आपका 70 से 80% इसी अटैक
को परफॉर्म करने में इसी को सिमुलेट करने
में आपका निकल जाता है। इसी अटैक को
सिमुलेट करने में आपका 70 से 80% टाइम
निकल जाता है। अब बात करता हूं मैं एक
रिपोर्ट की। आईएस आईएसटीआर की रिपोर्ट है
आई एसटीआर
आईएसटीआर पता है क्या होता है
आईएसटीआर क्या होता है एनीबडी
नो आईएसटीआर क्या होता है
आईएसटीआर
आईएसटीआर होता है इंटरनेट सिक्योरिटी
थ्रेट रिपोर्ट
ठीक है इंटरनेट सिक्योरिटी थ्रेट रिपोर्ट
इस रिपोर्ट के मुताबिक
टारगेटेड अटैक्स में जितने भी टारगेटेड
अटैक्स होते हैं इंटरनेट के ऊपर उसमें
सबसे बड़ा अटैक वेक्टर किसका है? स्पीयर
फेसिंग का। सबसे बड़ा अटैक वेक्टर किसका
है? स्पीयर फेसिंग का।
ठीक है? मतलब
डाटा जो जो डाटा है वह कहता है कि 65 टू
71%
ऑर्गेनाइज्ड ग्रुप चाहे वो आपके नेशन
स्टेट एक्टर्स हो चाहे वो साइबर क्रिमिनल
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन हो चाहे वो है एक्टिविस्ट
ग्रुप्स हो 65 टू 70%
ऑर्गेनाइज्ड ग्रुप क्या करते हैं अपने
ऑब्जेक्टिव को फुलफिल करने के लिए स्पेयर
फिशिंग का सहारा लेते हैं। मतलब अकॉर्डिंग
टू आईएसटीआर रिपोर्ट अकॉर्डिंग टू द
इंटरनेट सिक्योरिटी थ्रेट रिपोर्ट के
मुताबिक जितने भी जो ऑर्गेनाइज्ड ग्रुप्स
हैं जो भी साइबर क्राइम करते हैं अटैक
करते हैं चाहे वो नेशन स्टे अटैकर हो या
एक्टिविस्ट हो चाहे वो साइबर क्रिमिनल्स
हो या जो भी बड़े अटैक्स होते हैं फिशिंग
अटैक्स होते हैं उनमें मोस्ट कॉमन अटैक
कौन सा है आपका स्पीयर फिशिंग अटैक होता
है मोस्ट कॉमन अटैक कौन सा है स्पीयर
फिशिंग अटैक अटैक होता है। कौन सा होता
है? स्पीयर फिशिंग अटैक।
ओके? समझ में आ गया होगा। चलो एक
एग्जांपल देता हूं आपको रियल लेवल। एक एक
और एग्जांपल लेते हैं। इसका एक
एग्जीक्यूशन सिनेरियो देता हूं। फॉर
एग्जांपल आपने क्या किया कि आपने ओपन
सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस परफॉर्म की। किसी कंपनी
के बारे में। आपने पता लगाया कि वो कौन सा
एचआर वेंडरर्स या सर्विस प्रोवाइडर यूज
करती हैं। आपने सबसे पहले क्या है? एक
ओसेंट परफॉर्म किया। ओसेंट में आपने पता
लगाया कि कौन सा एचआर वेंडर
ह्यूमन रिसोर्सेज वेंडरर्स होते हैं। मतलब
थर्ड पार्टी की आप सर्विस ले रहे हो या
फिर कौन सा सर्विस प्रोवाइडर हम बोल सकते
हैं एसपी कौन सी सर्विस प्रोवाइडर से आप
सर्विस ले रहे हो। ये चीज आपने क्या है?
ड्यूरिंग ओसेंट कलेक्ट कर ली। उसके बाद
जैसे ही आपने ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस कलेक्ट
किया अपने टारगेट के बारे में। फिर आपने
क्या किया? एक फिशिंग ईमेल क्राफ्ट की एक
परफेक्ट फिशिंग ईमेल आपने क्या की क्राफ्ट
की और वो ऐसे क्राफ्ट की वो फेसिंग ईमेल
ऐसे बनाई कि बिल्कुल उनका जो एचआर
प्रोवाइडर है जैसा जो उनका एचआर
प्रोवाइडर्स होता है वह उसको मेल भेजता है
कंपनी को ऑफिशियली सेम वैसे ही उसी टाइप
का ईमेल एड्रेस उन्होंने यूज़ किया उनका
लोगो भी यूज़ किया उसके बाद किस टाइप के वह
वर्डिंग यूज़ करते हैं किस टाइप का
कम्युनिकेशन यूज़ करते हैं। किस टाइप की वह
लैंग्वेज यूज़ करते हैं। क्या उनका
पैटर्न्स होता है? वह सारे पैटर्न्स
उन्होंने अपने उस ईमेल में करप्ट किए और
ईमेल में कुछ सब्जेक्ट रखा एक्शन
रिक्वायर्ड कुछ अर्जेंसी कुछ उनके बेनिफिट
की बात की जैसे कि रिव्यू इनरोल इन
बेनिफिट मतलब कुछ ऐसी चीजें जिक्र की जो
क्या कर रहे थे? क्यूरोसिटी बढ़ा रहे थे।
ठीक है? जो साइकोलॉजिकल टेक्निक का यूज़
किया हो वो कसिटी बढ़ा रहे थे। और साथ में
क्या किया उन्होंने? इस ईमेल में एक लिंक
भी अटैच कर दिया। इस ईमेल में क्या किया?
एक लिंक भी अटैच कर दिया। और यह लिंक क्या
था? एक्चुअल
जो उनके जो एचआर सर्विस है
मतलब जिसके जिस सर्विस का उन्होंने फेक
क्रिएट किया है। सेम बिल्कुल हूबहू सेम
दिखने वाला उन्होंने क्या किया? उन्हीं के
वेबसाइट का एक क्लोन तैयार किया। क्या
किया? एक क्लोन तैयार किया। एक फेक
वेबसाइट तैयार की और जैसे ही एंप्लई वहां
पर आए क्योंकि फेक वेबसाइट है। डिफरेंस
कुछ है नहीं। बिल्कुल क्लोन है। एंप्लई ने
क्या किया? वहां पर अपने क्रेडेंशियल एंटर
किए और जैसे ही क्रेडेंशियल एंटर किए उनके
क्रेडेंशियल आपके पास आ गए। दिस इज ए
परफेक्ट प्रीप्लांट फिशिंग कैंपेन। स्पेयर
फिशिंग कैंपेन। समझ में आ गया? स्पेयर
फिशिंग कैंपेन एग्जांपल।
कैसे?
दिस इज ए परफेक्ट एग्जांपल ऑफ स्पेयर
फिशिंग। समझ में आया?
एवरीवन सबको समझ में आ गया स्पेयर फिशिंग
होती क्या है? कैसे परफॉर्म? यह पर
प्रैक्टिकली आपको एक जस्ट एक ओवरव्यू दिया
गया इस
पोस्टर के थ्रू। एवरीवन
फेक ईमेल कैसे बनाते हैं? तो यहां तो नहीं
दिखा सकता मैं
सिखाएंगे।
ओके। नेक्स्ट
अब बात करते हैं वेलिंग।
टारगेटिंग सीनियर एग्जीक्यूटिव्स।
अब बात आती है वेलिंग। वेलिंग क्या है?
वेलिंग क्या आपका एक एक्सट्रीम और हाई
लेवल वर्जन है। किसका? स्पीयर फिशिंग का।
यह क्या है? किसका? एक
हाई लेवल और एक्सट्रीम।
एक एक्सट्रीम वर्जन है किसका? स्पीयर
फिशिंग का। ठीक है? जिसको हम क्या बोलते
हैं? वेलिंग। वेलिंग का मतलब क्या होता
है? वेलिंग इज अ स्पेसिफिक टाइप ऑफ स्पीयर
फिशिंग एम्ड एट हाई लेवल हाई वैल्यू
इंडिविजुअल्स।
मतलब किसी भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस के अंदर
इसमें क्या किया जाता है? जो भी सीनियर
एग्जीक्यूटिव्स होते हैं सीएफओ, सीओ,
सीटीओ, सीओ, डायरेक्टर्स, वाइस
प्रेसिडेंट, बोर्ड मेंबर्स, सीनियर
मैनेजर्स या बाकी
बड़े व्यक्ति जो सीनियर एग्जीक्यूटिव होते
हैं किसी भी कंपनी के जो हाई वैल्यू
इंडिविल्स होते हैं उनको टारगेट किया जाता
है। है तो यह भी एक प्रकार का स्पीयर
फिशिंग बट बहुत ज़्यादा एडवांस स्पीयर
फिशिंग है जिसका नाम है वेलिंग जिसमें
क्या करते हो आप क्या करते हो सीनियर
एग्जीक्यूटिव को फंसाते हो मतलब दे आर
रेफर्ड टू एज ए बिग फिश ड्यू टू
सिग्निफिकेंट अथॉरिटी प्रिलज्ड एक्सेस एंड
क्रूशियल डिसीजन मेकिंग एबिलिटीज मतलब
इनको कहा जाता है कि बड़ी मछली को फंसाना
क्या कहा जाता है इसमें बड़ी मछली को
फंसाना ना ठीक है। क्योंकि बड़ी मछली
क्यों? क्योंकि इनके पास अथॉरिटी होती है।
इनके पास प्लेज्ड एक्सेस होते हैं। उनके
पास डिसीजन मेकिंग पावर्स होती है,
एबिलिटीज होती हैं। एंड ब्रीचिंग एन
एग्जीक्यूटिव अकाउंट कैन लीड टू
सिग्निफिकेंट क्सकेंसेस। और अगर आपने इनका
अकाउंट ब्रीच कर लिया तो इसके
क्सिक्वेंसेस सोचो कि आपने रिपोर्ट में
लिख दिया तो कितना बड़े सीरियस क्सक्वेंसेस
को आप उनके सामने एक्सपोज कर रहे हो।
एग्जीक्यूटिव ऑफेंस उनके पास क्या होते
हैं? कॉन्फिडेंशियल डॉक्यूमेंट्स होते
हैं। फाइनेंसियल अप्रूवल्स होते हैं। उनके
पास स्ट्रेटेजिक प्लांस होते हैं कंपनी
के। लीगल कम्युनिकेशंस की अथॉरिटी उनके
पास होती है। उनके प्लान होते हैं।
इन्वेस्टर्स की इंफॉर्मेशन होती है या
बहुत सारी सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन होती है।
और अगर आपने उनको क्या कर दिया?
कंप्रोमाइज कर लिया तो सोचो कि आपने पूरी
कंपनी को कंप्रोमाइज कर लिया। नेक्स्ट
वेलिंग डिमांड्स एज ए डिस्टिंक्ट
स्ट्रेटजी कंपेयर टू स्टैंडर्ड फेसिंग।
मतलब ये दोनों लाइन ऐसी है। आपको ऐसे समझ
में नहीं आएगा। मैं आपको बता देता हूं। बस
नॉर्मल आपको बताता मोटा-मोटा आपको नोट्स
मिल जाएंगे ना जब यह आप पढ़ लेना या आप
वीडियो में पॉज करके पढ़ लेना। मतलब क्या
है कि जो मेरा अपना एक्सपीरियंस है या
किसी भी बहुत सारे जो पेंटेस्टर्स हैं जो
मेरे से भी सीनियर्स पेंटेस्टर्स हैं जब
हम उनसे बातें करते हैं उनसे मिलते हैं
कभी कबभार और जब उनसे हमारी बातें होती
हैं तो उनके एक्सपीरियंस के हिसाब से एक
अजीब सी चीज सामने आई है। अजीब चीज क्या
है कि जितने भी जो हाई लेवल एग्जीक्यूटिव
होते हैं उनके पास एवरेज यूजर से ज्यादा
ट्रस्ट वो क्या होते हैं? एवरेज यूजर से
ज्यादा ट्रस्टेड होते हैं। ठीक है? उनका
जो सिक्योरिटी एक्सेस है वह बहुत ज्यादा
होता है। वह उनका जो सिस्टम्स होता है जो
उनका पीसी होता है जो लैपटॉप यूज़ करते हैं
वो क्या करते हैं? उस लैपटॉप के लोकल
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर होते हैं। और आप समझो कि
आपने अगर उनको कंप्रोमाइज कर लिया मतलब
आपने पूरा नेटवर्क कंप्रोमाइज कर लिया।
मतलब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आपने उनका
पूरा नेटवर्क कंप्रोमाइज कर लिया। हां और
एक और चीज मैं आपको बता देता हूं कि
अभी जो ये अटैक स्ट्रेटजी होती है जो इन
दो लाइन में आपको एक्सप्लेन किया गया है।
दो लाइन में आपको बताया गया है। उनका मतलब
मैं आपको बताता हूं जो विलिंग जो वेलिंग
अटैक है उसको परफॉर्म करने की स्ट्रेटजी
बहुत अलग होती है। कैसे? मान के चलो एक
चीफ फाइनेंसियल ऑफ ऑफिसर है सीएफओ है आप
उसको कोई हेल्प डेस्क या जो सेल्समैन गाय
को ईमेल भेजने वाले थे व्यक्ति को आप
भेजने वाले थे वो वाली ईमेल तो नहीं
भेजोगे उसको क्योंकि जो सीएफओ का माइंडसेट
है और जो एक रिसेप्शन पे बैठने वाला
रिसेप्शनिस्ट है या जो हेल्थ टैक्स पे
बैठने वाले जो मेंबर्स हैं या फिर जो एक
सेल्समैन है उसके माइंडसेट से बिल्कुल अलग
माइंडसेट होता है। आप उन वाली फिशिंग मेल
आप इसके पास नहीं भेज सकते क्योंकि सीएफओ
को फंसाने के लिए या इन एग्जीक्यूटिव
ऑफिसर्स को या एग्जीक्यूटिव लेवल्स को
फंसाने के लिए आपके पास अलग अप्रोच फॉलो
करनी पड़े होगी। मतलब आपके पास उनकी
एग्जैक्ट डिटेल होनी चाहिए। उनका एग्जैक्ट
नाम होना चाहिए। उनकी एग्जैक्ट पोजीशन
होनी चाहिए। आपके पास ऐसी इंफॉर्मेशन होनी
चाहिए। आपके पास ऐसी डिटेल्स होनी चाहिए
उनके प्लेटफॉर्म्स की या फिर उनके
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन की जो सिर्फ हायर
एग्जीक्यूटिव के पास ही होती है क्योंकि
बहुत सारी ऐसी डिटेल्स होती है वो कभी भी
नॉर्मल एंप्लई के साथ शेयर नहीं की जाती
और अगर आपने बड़ी मछली को फंसाना है तो
उसी लेवल की आपके पास इंफॉर्मेशन हो जाए
ताकि जब आप उनके साथ कनेक्शन बिल्ड करोगे
आपका कनेक्शन स्ट्रांग बने। ऐसे नहीं कि
आपने पता चला कि एक नॉर्मल किसी भी एंप्लई
को फीसिंग ईमेल भेज तो सेम एंप्लई इनको भी
भेज दे। वह आपको तुरंत पकड़ लेगा। बिकॉज़
दोनों का माइंड सेट एक माइंडसेट लोअर लेवल
और एक अप्पर लेवल माइंडसेट है। दोनों का
माइंडसेट बहुत अलग होता है। तो ये चीज सोच
के आपको करनी पड़ेगी। फॉर एग्जांपल या
आपको एक एग्जांपल मैं आपको बता सकता हूं।
क्या कर सकते हो आप? जैसे कि वो किसी ऐसे
प्रोफेशनल ग्रुप का मेंबर्स हैं या आप
किसी ट्रेड ऑर्गेनाइजेशन ग्रुप का मेंबर्स
हैं। फॉर एग्जांपल ज्यादातर सीनियर
एग्जीक्यूटिव क्या करते हैं? मैं आपको
एग्जांपल देता हूं कि वो गोलफ खेलना पसंद
करते हैं। ठीक है? वो गोलफ क्लब ज्वाइन
करते हैं। मतलब जहां पर अमीर बैठते हैं ना
वहां पर वो वाले शौक उनको पालते हैं।
स्पेशल स्टेडियम में जाएंगे, स्पेशल जिम
में जाएंगे, उनकी मेंबरशिप ले लेंगे,
स्पेशल कोच होगा। उनके ग्रुप्स का वो
अक्सर पार्ट हो सकते हैं। तो आप अगर आपने
उनका जिनका वो मेंबर्स है उसका पार्ट बनके
उनको मैसेज किया उनको ट्रैप करने की कोशिश
करी तो मतलब वो ट्रस्टेड सोर्स बनेगा या
फिर आपने और यह करने के लिए भी एक और चीज
है। दो दो रिक्वायरमेंट है या एक ही
रिक्वायरमेंट काफी है। जिसका वह मेंबर है
उनकी इंटरनल लिंगो सीखनी पड़ेगी। मतलब वह
बातचीत कैसे करते हैं? किस टाइप से वह
बातचीत करते हैं। किस टाइप की मैसेजिंग
रहती है? मतलब ऐसी नहीं कि आप कोई जनरल
मैसेज कर दोगे क्योंकि जब हाई अथॉरिटी के
साथ बात करते हो कि उनके पैटर्न भी अलग
होते हैं। उसके सामने वाले कम्युनिकेशन
डील अलग होती है और जो एक्चुअल में सीएफओ
है, सीईओ है, सीटीओ है या जो भी सीसो है
उनका अपना डील होता है। वो सारी चीजें
आपको सीखनी पड़ेंगे। उसी हिसाब से आपको
अपनी क्राफ्टिंग करनी पड़ेगी। प्री
टेक्स्टिंग करनी पड़ेगी। उसी हिसाब को
आपको अपनी टेक्निक यूज़ करनी पड़ेगी। आई
होप समझ में आ गया होगा वेलिंग का मतलब
क्या है
कि वेलिंग क्या चीज है? किस बला का नाम
है? और किसको आप टारगेट करने जा रहे हो?
अवेलिंग में आपको किन-किन चीजों का ध्यान
ध्यान रखना है?
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
अंडरस्टुड? बाकी लोग बताइए।
चलो
अभी नेक्स्ट आते हैं हम हमारी नेक्स्ट
टेक्निक पर दैट इज कॉल्ड वेस्टिंग वॉइस
बेस्ड सोशल इंजीनियरिंग। मतलब
ये हमारी अब ये हमारी थोड़ी सी एक इंटर
इंटरेक्टिव अटैक वेक्टर है जिसको हम बोलते
हैं वेसिंग यानी फोन के जरिए किया जाने
वाला सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक। विशिंग का
मतलब क्या है? फोन के जरिए किया जाने वाला
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक किसके अंदर आता है?
विशिंग टेक्निक के अंदर। ठीक है? विशिंग
टेक्निक के अंदर। विशिंग में क्या होता है
कि विशिंग में
क्या होता है? अब देखते हैं। विशिंग इज ए
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक कंडक्टेड बाय फोन
कॉल्स और वॉइस कम्युनिकेशन।
वॉइस कम्युनिकेशन। इन दिस मेथड द अटैकर
इंगेज इन ए डायरेक्ट कन्वर्जेशन विद द
टारगेट अटेमप्टिंग टू इन्फ्लुएंस देम थ्रू
डायलॉग। इसका मतलब क्या है? कि विशिंग में
अटैकर टारगेट को कॉल करता है और फोन पर
उनसे बातें करके उनको इन्फ्लुएंस करने की
कोशिश करता है और इन्फ्लुएंस कोशिश करके
इंफॉर्मेशन निकलवाने की कोशिश करता है।
मतलब सारा काम जो सोशल इंजीनिंग अटैक होता
है जो अभी तक आप फेसिंग ईमेल भेज रहे थे,
फेसिंग एसएमएस भेज रहे थे वह सारा काम आप
किस पे करने की कोशिश कर रहे हो? फोन के
ऊपर फोन के द्वारा। एंड दिस मेथड इज मोर
इंटैक्टिव देन ईमेल फेसिंग। इंटरेक्टिव तो
है लेकिन नॉर्मल फिशिंग से भी बहुत ज्यादा
मुश्किल टेक्निक है। कैसे मुश्किल है? इन
फिशिंग द अटैकर कैन मिसली क्राफ्ट एंड
रिवाइव द मैसेज प्रीियर टू सेंड इट।
फिशिंग में आप क्या कर सकते हो? आपके पास
सोचने और मेल लिखने का बहुत ज्यादा टाइम
होता है। बहुत सारा टाइम होता है। हाउएवर
इन विशिंग द अटैकर ऑपरेट इन ए रियल टाइम।
जो अटैकर्स होता है रियल टाइम में ऑपरेट
करता है। दे नीड टू थिंक ऑन देयर फीट कीप
देयर नैरेटिव कंसिस्टेंट एड्रेस अनफोर्स
इन क्वेश्चंस एंड साउंड कन्विंसिंग मतलब
क्या है कि एक तो रियल टाइम में ऑपरेट
करता है। आपको क्या करना पड़ता है विशिंग
के अंदर जो स्टोरी है वो पहले से रेडी
आपको रखनी है। आपकी जो स्टोरी है पहले से
रेडी होनी चाहिए। उसके बाद नेक्स्ट चैलेंज
के लिए भी रेडी रहना चाहिए। हो सकता है कि
टारगेट आपसे कोई ऐसा अजीब सा सवाल पूछ ले
पूछ लिया जाए जिसके लिए आप रेडी नहीं थे।
मतलब टारगेट ने आपसे ऐसा सवाल पूछ लिया
जिसके बारे में आपने सोचा ही नहीं था। तो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] उस चीज के
लिए भी आपको रेडी होना पड़ेगा और आपके पास
सबसे बड़ी पता क्या क्वालिटी होनी चाहिए?
ऑन द स्पॉट झूठ बोलने की क्वालिटी होनी
चाहिए। स्विसिंग अटैक करने के लिए जब आप
पूरी स्टोरी भी तैयार कर लेते हो तब भी एक
चैलेंज हमेशा सामने रहता है कि सामने वाला
ऐसा अनएक्सेक्टेड क्वेश्चन पूछ सकता है
जिसका जवाब आपके पास ना हो तो इसीलिए आपके
पास सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट क्वालिटी क्या होनी
चाहिए झूठ बोलने की ऑन द सपोर्ट झूठ बोलने
की ऑन द सपोर्ट आप क्या कर पाओ उसका आंसर
उसी के तरीके से दे पाओ ताकि वह कन्वेंस
हो जाए दिस इज ए सबसे बड़ी क्वालिटी होती
है अब विशिंग में चैलेंज भी बहुत हैं। हो
सकता है सामने वाला फोन ना उठाए या फिर आप
विशिंग टेक्निक अप्लाई कर रहे हो और आपके
पास एग्जैक्ट डिटेल नहीं है। मतलब उतनी
डिटेल्स नहीं है और सबसे बड़ी प्रॉब्लम
आपने ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस परफॉर्म की। आप
क्या कर रहे हो? एक किसी
और व्यक्ति का कैरेक्टर प्ले करोगे। अब
बाय चांस आपने जो कैरेक्टर प्ले किया
जिसका नाम लेकर आप बेसिंग परफॉर्म कर रहे
हो वह उसी के साइड वाले कैबिन या उसी के
क्यूबिकल में बैठा बैठा है और आपने उसी का
नाम यूज़ कर लिया पकड़े गए या फिर आपने जो
आइडेंटिटी यूज़ की उसमें मेल फीमेल का रोल
था नाम के बेसिस पे वो आइडेंटिटी आप सही
से यूज़ नहीं कर पाए तब भी आप क्या गए आप
पकड़े गए तो ये सारे डर किसके अंदर क्या
है फिशिंग के अंदर हमेशा बने रहेंगे
विशिंग के अंदर ठीक है ये सारे डर और यह
सारी चीजें आपको कैलकुलेट करनी पड़ेगी और
इन सारी चीजों के हिसाब से आपको हमेशा
रेडी रहना पड़ेगा। नेक्स्ट वॉइस फिशिंग का
एक एग्जांपल देते हैं। देखो अभी हम बात
करते हैं इस साइड में क्या है? ईमेल
फेसिंग है और यह है वॉइस फेसिंग है।
कंपैरिजन कर रहा हूं। देखो ईमेल फेसिंग
में क्या होता है? आपको क्या करना पड़ता
है? आपको वेट करना पड़ता है। बहुत सारा
वेट करना पड़ता है और फोन पर आपको क्या
करता है? तुरंत रिस्पांस मिल जाता है।
यहां पर आपको वेट करना पड़ेगा। सामने वाला
कब क्लिक करेगा, कब आपके ट्रैप में आएगा?
यू डोंट नो। बस यहां पर क्या है? रियल
टाइम कन्वर्जेशन हो रहा है। ठीक है? ऑन द
सपोर्ट क्या कर रहे हो आप? कॉलर आईडी
स्पुफिंग कर रहे हो। क्या कर सकते हो आप?
स्पुफिंग एप्लीकेशन का यूज़ करते हो।
स्पुफिंग एप्लीकेशन का यूज़ करके आप क्या
करोगे कि वो नंबर डिस्प्ले करवाओगे जो लगे
कि हां उन्हीं के कंपनी के अंदर से है।
कोई उन्हीं के नोन से है। उसके बाद
अथॉरिटी और ट्रस्ट गेन करोगे। अर्जेंसी ऑफ
प्रेशर बनाओगे और आप उससे इंफॉर्मेशन
निकलवाने की कोशिश करोगे। ओके? उससे
इंफॉर्मेशन निकलवाने की कोशिश करोगे।
लेकिन ईमेल में क्या है? फेसिंग ईमेल में
फेसिंग ईमेल में आपको क्या करना पड़ता है?
आपको वेट करना पड़ता है। अब कॉल करने के
लिए आप बोल सकते हो मैं किसी आईटी सर्वे
से बात कर रहा हूं। मैं यह वेंडर हूं या
कोई कस्टमर हूं। सो एंड सो बहुत सारे
बहाने होते हैं जिनसे आप बहाना बना के कॉल
कर सकते हो। बट मैंने आपको बताया जो
चैलेंज है वो चैलेंज हमेशा रहेंगे। दिस इज
ए वॉइस फिशिंग। अब वॉइस फिशिंग काम कैसे
करती है देख लें। पहले क्या करते हैं? इस
टाइप से आप पूरा सेटअप इस्टैब्लिश करते
हो। उसके बाद कोई आइडेंटिटी क्लेम करते
हो। उसके बाद एंप्लई आपसे बात करने की
कोशिश करता है। रियल टाइम कन्वर्जेशन होती
है आपकी। उसके बाद चांसेस यहां पर रहते
हैं 50-50।
50-50 ही चांस रहते हैं कि हो सकता है
आपको इंफॉर्मेशन मिल भी जाए और हो सकता है
कि 50% सेम टाइम अब रिजेक्ट भी होगा।
देयर इज नो गारंटी कि आप जो इंफॉर् लेने
की कोशिश कर रहे हो आपको मिलेगी या नहीं
मिलेगी। लेकिन अगर आपका प्रीक्स सॉलिड है।
आपकी कन्वेंशन पावर सॉलिड है। किस-किस ने
यहां पर जमतारा मूवी देखी है।
जमतारा इज द परफेक्ट एग्जांपल ऑफ मिसिंग।
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग में जमतार इज अ परफेक्ट
एग्जांपल ऑफ विशिंग। किस-किस ने देखी है?
सबने देखी होगी ना जमताजा सीरीज
एवरीवन
जमतार एक सीरीज है वो देखो
निखिल कुमार अभी आप आपकी फर्स्ट क्लास है।
एक भी क्लास मत मिस मत करना। अपकमिंग
जितनी भी क्लासेस आएंगी मैं आपको क्लियरली
बताऊंगा कि सोशल इंजीनियरिंग में एथिकल्स
और नॉन एथिकल चीजें क्या होती हैं। आप कब
कर सकते हो और कब नहीं कर सकते। डूज और
डोंट क्या कर सकते हो और क्या नहीं कर
सकते? यह सारी चीजें मैं डिटेल्स में
बताऊंगा। डोंट
स्किप एनी क्लास। आज आप आगे प्रीवियस
क्लास को देखने की कोशिश कीजिए और नेक्स्ट
क्लासेस को ज्वाइन कीजिए। डोंट मिस आउट
एनी सिंगल क्लास।
एवरीवन मेरी रिक्वेस्ट है मैं सबसे
प्रॉमिस करता हूं कि उसमें ऐसी चीजें
आएंगी।
ओके? तो, यह था आपका विशिंग। नेक्स्ट आते
हैं आपके बेटिंग पर। बेटिंग क्या होता है?
बेटिंग क्या होता है? बेटिंग का मतलब होता
है आपका लालच देना।
वेटिंग का मतलब होता है लालच देना। बैटिंग
इज ए सोशल इंजीनियरिंग टैिक इन वि अटैकर
प्रेजेंट ए अपीलिंग ऑफर टू प्रम द टारगेट
टू टेक ए स्पेसिफिक एक्शन। मतलब आप क्या
करते हो? सामने वाले टारगेट को कोई ऑफर
देते हो। कोई लालच देते हो। कोई टोकन का
ऑफर, किसी रिचार्ज कूपन का ऑफर या आपने
फ्री में कुछ प्रीमियम दे दिया या किसी
चीज का एक्सेस देने की ऑफर। यह सारी चीजें
आप क्या करते हो? ऑफर देते हो ताकि वह
यूजर उसके ऊपर कोई ना कोई स्पेसिफिक
एक्सेस परफॉर्म करें। अभी यह जो ऑफर है
जिसकी हम बात कर रहे हैं द बेट कैन टेक
वेरियस फॉर्म्स। ठीक है? अब यह ऑफर फिजिकल
भी हो सकता है और डिजिटल भी हो सकता है।
अगर हम फिजिकल की बात करें तो आप यहां पर
क्या यूज़ करते हो? USB ड्राइव्स। अगर हम
USB ड्राइव्स ठीक है? या हम डिजिटल की बात
करें डिजिटल डिजिटल जमाने में आप यूज़ करते
हो क्यूआर कोड या आपने कोई फेक गिफ्ट
कंप्लीमेंट्री गिफ्ट उसको भेज दिया।
डिसेप्टिव डाउनलोड्स यह सारी चीजें हैं।
कोई फॉल सॉफ्टवेयर अपडेट्स मतलब फिजिकल भी
हो सकता है और डिजिटल और ज्यादातर फिजिकल
में बात करें तो इसमें USB ड्राइव का यूज़
किया जाता है। और डिजिटल जमाने में बात
करें तो क्यूआर कोड का यूज़ किया जाता है
किसी को क्या करने के लिए? लालच देने के
लिए। तो जैसे आप बात करते हैं ये रहा। फॉर
एग्जांपल एक एग्जांपल लेते हैं कि आपने
क्या किया? एक USB ड्राइव ली। ठीक है? मैं
दोनों एग्जांपल बताऊं। आप एक नॉर्मल USB
ड्राइव भी ले सकते हो या कोई एक जिसका नाम
रबर डकी डकी ड्राइव। ठीक है जिसमें
मिलिशियस ड्राइव तो आपने क्या किया उस
कंपनी के या तो किसी पार्किंग लॉट में
उसको क्या कर दिया ड्रॉप कर दिया या उसके
बिल्डिंग एंट्रेंस में ड्रॉप कर दिया या
जहां पर कैफिट एरिया में अक्सर वो जाते
रहते हैं खाना खाते हैं ब्रेकफास्ट करते
हैं उनके कैफिटरिया में ड्रॉप कर दिया और
उनके नाम कैसे कर दिए रीनेम कर दिया एक
अट्रैक्टिव रीनेम जैसे एंप्लॉय सैलरी
इंफॉर्मेशन एग्जीक्यूटिव नोट्स है
कॉन्फिडेंशियल रिपोर्ट है एचआर के
बेनिफिट्स है या पे रोल से रिलेटेड
इंफॉर्मेशन या कंपनी का कुछ पॉलिसी
अनाउंसमेंट होने वाली है मतलब उसमें उसमें
कुछ ट्रस्टेड और क्यूरियस वाली चीजें
उसमें ऐड कर दी और आपने इन जगह उनको क्या
कर दिया? ड्रॉप कर दिया। ठीक है? अभी जब
आपने ड्रॉप कर दिया तो भैया कोई ना कोई तो
उसको उठाएगा ही क्यूरियोसिटी में आके कोई
ना कोई तो उठाएगा। अभी यहां पर दो दो टाइप
के ड्राइव या तो आप क्या कर सकते हो? एक
स्टैंडर्ड USB ड्राइव ड्रॉप कर सकते हो
टेस्टिंग के लिए। आपको नुकसान नहीं
पहुंचा। नॉर्मल पेन टेस्टिंग करनी है
अकॉर्डिंग टू अथॉरिटी। बस तो आपने क्या कर
दिया? एक स्टैंडर्ड USB ड्राइव शो करती
है। लेकिन स्टैंडर्ड USB ड्राइव में
प्रॉब्लम क्या होती है कि जो डीएलपी
सॉफ्टवेयर होते हैं ना कंपनी में हर एक
कंपनी में होते हैं। लगभग कौन से होते
हैं? डीएलपी मैं लिखता हूं डीएलपी
सॉफ्टवेयर। डीएलपी डाटा लॉस प्रिवेंशन
सॉफ्टवेयर। ये क्या करते हैं? सेम टाइम
नॉर्मल यूएसबी को डिटेक्ट कर लेंगे और
डिटेक्ट करके ब्लॉक कर देंगे। आगे उसको
फ़ोर्सफुली ओपन किया जाए। किसी
एंप्लई के द्वारा उसको मैनुअली एग्जिट
करवाया जाए तो पॉसिबल है। बट यह सेम टाइम
लगता है इसको ब्लॉक कर देते हैं। वहीं पर
जो दूसरी यूएसबी ड्राइव होती है जिसको रबर
डकी बोलते हैं जिसको हम क्या बोलते हैं?
रबर डकी। ठीक है? जिसके अंदर क्या होता है
कि
वो मिलिशियस होती है। मतलब जैसे ही लगेगी
उसमें अपना काम स्टार्ट हो जाए। कीबोर्ड
टाइप का उसमें रहेगा। ओके? तो उसमें क्या
जो डीएलपी है यह बाईपास हो जाता है। रबर
डकी में चांसेस हाई होते हैं कि डीएलपी
बाईपास हो जाता है। यह सोचता है कि ओके
कोई ऐसा व्यक्ति है जिसकी टाइपिंग स्पीड
बहुत ज्यादा है जो टाइप कर रहा लग गई और
इस भ्रम में निकाल के डीएलपी बाईपास हो
जाता है। ठीक है? बट बट बट बट यह क्या है?
किसी ने मुझसे पूछा था प्रीवियस क्लास में
सर फिजिकल अटैक कोई टेक्निक है सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग की? यही वह फिजिकल अटैक
टेक्निक है। ठीक है? रबर डकी या फिर आपका
कोई यह क्या हो गया आपका
नॉर्मल USB ड्राइव है टेस्टिंग के लिए।
हां। लेकिन जो वेटिंग होती है उस वो बहुत
ज्यादा रिस्की भी होती है। आप मान सकते हो
उसको रिस्की भी बोल सकते हो। कैसे रिस्की
हो सकती है? आपको नहीं पता कि उस ड्राई को
कौन उठाएगा? क्या आपको पता है उस ड्राई को
कौन उठाएगा? नोबडी नोज़। हो सकता है कोई
ऐसा एमंप्लई उठाए उसको घर ले गया और घर
लेकर जाकर अपने कंप्यूटर में प्लग इन कर
लिया भैया उसने क्या किया खुद के कंप्यूटर
में प्लग इन किया आपको किसका एक सेल
एक्सेस मिला उसके कंप्यूटर का और
अकॉर्डिंग टू द ऑथराइजेशन अकॉर्डिंग टू द
रूल ऑफ इंगेजमेंट या अकॉर्डिंग टू द
पॉलिसी
आपको उसके पर्सनल कंप्यूटर को हैक करने की
परमिशन नहीं थी उसके पर्सनल ल कंप्यूटर की
टेस्टिंग की परमिशन नहीं थी। मतलब
आपका स्कोप कंट्रोल आउट ऑफ स्कोप हो गया।
अनइटेंशनली
आउट ऑफ स्कोप हो गए। वो लीगल एक्शन भी हो
सकता है। तो इस चीज का भी ध्यान रखना
आपको। ड्यूरिंग
वेटिंग। यह भी सरकमस्ट्ससेस हैं। यह भी हो
सकता है। ऐसा नहीं कि यह नहीं हो सकता। यह
हो सकता है। तो नेक्स्ट आता है आपका
डमस्टर ड्राइविंग।
डमस्टर ड्राइविंग क्या होता है? मैं आपको
बता देता हूं। ठीक है? अब डमस्टर
ड्राइविंग का मतलब होता है कि
कोई भी टारगेट ऑफिस है, कोई भी टारगेट
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है, उसके
ट्रेस बैग को उठाना या उसके कचरे वाले
डिब्बे को उठाना।
ठीक है?
और उठाकर उसको ऐसी जगह लेकर जाना, ऐसी
सुनसान जगह लेकर जाना जहां से उस कचरे को
फिल्टर आउट किया जा सके। उसको डिटेक्ट
किया जा सके और वहां से सेंसिटिव
इंफॉर्मेशन निकाली जा सके। बोला सर क्या
बोल रहे हो? कचरे में क्या मिलता है? सर
बोला कि कचरे में क्या मिलता है? और कौन
ऐसा करेगा? सर मैं किसी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन में
जाऊंगा और कचरा उठा के और उनके कचरे से यह
काम करूंगा। बट यह रियलिटी है भाई।
इंफॉर्मेशन लेने के लिए
यह रियलिटी है।
ऐसा होता है।
ठीक है? क्योंकि बहुत सारे लोग क्या करते
हैं? आपकी खुद के जो पर्सनल है या जो
सेंसिटिव चीजें होते हैं उसको बिना श्रेड
किए। श्रेड क्या होता है? उसको एक मशीन
होती है। उस मशीन में डालते हैं।
टुकड़े-टुकड़े में उसको वो कर देते हैं।
उसको बिना श्रेड किए क्या करते हैं? कचरे
में डाल देते हैं डायरेक्टली सीधा ऑफिस के
डॉक्यूमेंट भी पर्सनल इंफॉर्मेशन भी होगी
उनके लायक या कुछ चीजें पसंद थी और उससे
क्या होगा
वो कचरे के डिब्बे में है अब जो कचरे वाला
है उसको साथ में लेके जाएगा इसलिए लोग खुद
कचरे वाला बन के जाते हैं ठीक है डमस्टर
ड्राइविंग करते हैं ठीक है हां उसमें हो
सकता है कि बाकी बहुत सारा कैफिटरिया का
कचरा भी हो सकता है टॉयलेट का भी कचरा हो
सकता है बहुत सारा यूज़ यूज़लेस कचरा दूसरा
भी हो सकता है बट इंफॉर्मेशन के लिए लोग
करते हैं। इंफॉर्मेशन के लिए लोग करते
हैं। ठीक है? एंड एक लाइन इसमें न्यूमरस
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन प्लेसेस सिग्निफिकेंट
इमफेजेस ऑन डिजिटल सिक्योरिटी व्हाइल
ओवरलुकिंग देंस ऑफ फिजिकल इंफॉर्मेशन
सिक्योरिटी। बहुत सारी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन क्या
करती है? अपनी डिजिटल सिक्योरिटी को
प्रोटेक्ट करने के लिए लाखों करोड़ों रुपए
खर्च करती है। लेकिन फिजिकल इंफॉर्मेशन
सिक्योरिटी केेंस को ओवरलुक कर देती है।
ठीक है? क्योंकि उनके एंप्लाइजज़ को यह पता
ही नहीं कि चीजों को श्रेड भी करना है,
डिस्ट्रॉय भी करना है। ठीक है?
उसको डिस्ट्रॉय भी करना है और इस चीज की
भी अवेयरनेस कम होती है कि आपके जो आपके
जो डंप्स बैग्स हैं या आपके जो ड्रेस
बैग्स है उसमें भी आप सेंसिटिव इनेशन छोड़
सकते हो। ठीक है? जैसे कि एग्जांपल लेते
हैं। इसकी प्रोसेस क्या होती है? फॉर
एग्जांपल आप क्या किया? आपने एक कचरा
उठाने वाले
वाले की यूनिफार्म पहनी। ठीक है? हाथ में
ग्लव्स पहन लिए, मुंह पर मास्क लगा लिया।
मतलब अपना प्री टैक्स फिर से स्ट्रांग कर
लिया।
ग्लव्स, कचरा उठाने वाले की जैकेट, मुंह
पर मास्क पहन लिया और उसके बाद क्या किया?
आप कचरा उठाने के बहाने उनके कचरे वाले
पॉइंट तक पहुंचते हो। ठीक है? पर्सनल ऑफिस
स्पेस में नहीं पहुंचते। लेकिन उसके जहां
पर जहां से कचरा रहता है, ठीक है? वहां तक
आप पहुंचते हो। उसके बाद आपने क्या किया?
उस कचरे को उठाया। उठाकर क्या लेके जाते
हो? आप उसको ऑफ साइड लेके जाते हो। अपनी
लैब में लेके जाते हो। और अपनी लैब में
लेके जाकर उसको क्या करते हो? उसको फिल्टर
आउट करते हो। ठीक है? उसको कलेक्ट करते
हो। फिल्टर आउट करते हो। अगर कोई ऐसी
इंफॉर्मेशन है जो फटी हुई है, ट्रेस कर
दिया उसको क्या करते हो? आप टेप से जोड़ते
हो। जोड़ के उस इंफॉर्मेशन को कलेक्ट करने
की कोशिश करते हो। ठीक है? मैच करने की
कोशिश करते हो। हो सकता है कि जो
इंफॉर्मेशन ट्रेस कर रखी है उनके पीसेस को
आपने जोड़-जोड़ के जोड़-जोड़ के जोड़-जोड़
के आपने क्या किया?
वह इंफॉर्मेशन निकालिए जो हो सकता है आपके
बड़े नेक्स्ट स्टेप के लिए बहुत ज्यादा
वैल्यूएबल हो। बहुत ज्यादा
वैल्यू प्रोवाइड करें। बहुत ज्यादा
इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड करें। और ऐसा नहीं
है। ये चीज करने के लिए क्या है कि बहुत
सारे लोग या तो हाई स्कूल के बच्चे या
कॉलेज स्टूडेंट्स का सहारा लेते हैं। उनको
पैसा देते हैं और उनसे ये काम करवाते भी
हैं। इन रियलिटी जो भी कॉलेज स्टूडेंट्स
हैं या उनको जो हाई स्कूल के स्टूडेंट को
कुछ पैसे ऑफर करेंगे और उनसे ये काम
करवाते भी हैं और इंफॉर्मेशन अपने पास ले
आएंगे। उस कचरे को बैग को अपने पास मंगवा
लेंगे और फिर उसमें से इंफॉर्मेशन फिल्टर
आउट करेंगे। रियलिटी है। ठीक है? यह आपकी
रियलिटी है। तो इस तरीके से क्या है कि
आपके जो कचरे के डिब्बे होते हैं उनमें भी
बहुत सारी इंपॉर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन होती है।
जो
सिक्योरिटी या अवेयरनेस ट्रेनिंग के बिना
लोगों को अवेयरनेस नहीं होती और वह ऐसीऐसी
इंफॉर्मेशन कचरे के डिब्बे में डाल देते
हैं। ऐसीऐसी इनेशन कोई नोट हो गया कोई
छोटी सी चिट होगी हो सकता है किसी की ईमेल
एड्रेस हो किसी का इंपॉर्टेंट अह ईमेल्स
हो या कुछ शेड्यूल हो कोई कंपनी का इंटरनल
प्लान हो या एंप्लई का पूरी एक
लिस्ट थी उसके अंदर आ गई तो बहुत सारी ऐसी
इंफॉर्मेशन जो हम जाने अनजाने में कचरे
में फेंक देते हैं बिना उसको स्ल्रेड किए
और स्ल्रेड करने के बाद भी ठीक है श्रेड
करने के बाद भी उसको मिक्स नहीं करते।
श्रेड कर दिया उसके बाद उसको इधर से उधर
मिक्स नहीं करते। तो क्या है कि किसी भी
एक अटैकर्स के लिए एक पेंटेस्टस के लिए वो
काफी वैल्यू ऐड कर सकती है। काफी वैल्यू
क्या कर सकती है? वो ऐड कर सकती है। तो
जैसे कि हमने डिस्कस किया हमने क्या-क्या
डिस्कस किया? हमने डिस्कस किया कि अब चाहे
वह ईमेल हो, चाहे वह फोन कॉल हो, चाहे वह
फिजिकल यूएसबी हो या फिर वह कचरे से ही
क्यों ना हो। एक अटैकर
उस ऑर्गेनाइजेशन में एंटर करने के लिए वह
डमस्टर ड्राइविंग का भी सहारा ले सकता है।
वेटिंग का भी सहारा ले सकता है। वििंग का
भी सहारा ले सकता है। वेलिंग का भी सहारा
ले सकता है। फिशिंग का भी सहारा ले सकता
है। प्रीटेक्स्टिंग,
स्मिसिंग, टेल गेटिंग इन सारी टेक्निक का
सहारा लेके या स्पेयर फिशिंग इन सारी
टेक्निक का क्या करता है? वह सहारा लेता
है। और उसके बाद क्या करता है? उस
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के अंदर एंटर करने का रास्ता
खोजता है और एंट्री लेने की कोशिश करता
है। तो दी आर द सम मोस्ट कॉमन मोस्ट
पॉपुलर टाइप्स ऑफ सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
अटैक्स।
तो यहां तक यह था मेरा सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
का फंडामेंटल्स। मैंने आज और कल की क्लास
में बहुत सारी चीजें क्लियर की। कौन-कौन
सी चीजें क्लियर की? कि सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
होती क्या है? उसकी हिस्ट्री क्या है? ठीक
है? सोशल इंजीनियरिंग में
मतलब कि एक्चुअल में क्या-क्या चीजें
मायने रखती हैं। ठीक है? मॉडर्न मॉडर्न
पेंटस्टिंग में सोशल इंजीनियरिंग कितनी
हेल्पफुल है और उसके जितने भी टाइप्स हैं
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग कितने टाइप से परफॉर्म
की जा सकती है? सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक
कितने तरीकों से किया जा सकता है वह सारी
चीजें वन बाय वन काफी डिटेल्स में मैंने
बहुत कुछ आप लोगों को प्रोवाइड किया है।
बहुत कुछ आप लोगों को आपके सामने मैंने
आपको काफी डिटेल्स में शेयर किया है। तो
अगर आपको किसी को भी इसमें कोई भी डाउट है
रिलेटेड टू दिस टॉपिक देन
यू कैन आस्क मी नाउ। आप लोग मुझसे पूछ
सकते हो। नाउ योर डाउट सेशन इज ओपन।
अभी आप मुझसे आप अपने डाउट्स ले पूछ सकते
हो। आज का टॉपिक इतना ही था अभी तक।
किसी का कोई सवाल है रिलेटेड टू द फेसिंग,
रिलेटेड टू द सोशल इंजीनियरिंग, रिलेटेड
टू द क्लास या कोई भी जनरल सवाल जो मुझसे
पूछना चाहता है।
सबको क्लास में मजा आया?
मैं ओनली क्लास आपको अच्छी लगी नहीं लगी।
मैं ओनली लाइव वाले स्टूडेंट से ही नहीं
पूछता। अगर आप ऑफलाइन हो रिकॉर्डिंग सेशन
भी देखते हो। अगर आप लोगों को क्लास पसंद
आ रही है, आपको अच्छी लग रही है तो प्लीज
कमेंट कर दिया करो ताकि बाकी लोग जो आते
हैं क्लास देखने के लिए उनको पता चल जाए
कि ओके क्लासेस में सच में बहुत सारी
वैल्यू है।
रबर डकी कैसे बनाते हैं? उसके लिए तो भैया
ट्रेनिंग देनी पड़ेगी आप लोगों को।
करो रिसर्च पहले
उसके लिए बहुत सारी नॉलेज चाहिए होती है।
आपको एक्सप्लेन बनाने आने चाहिए। आप लोगों
को बहुत सारी नॉलेज होनी चाहिए। ऐसा नहीं
कि आप जस्ट ए बिगिनियर आप उसको कर पाओगे।
ठीक है?
बट कर सकते हो। ऐसा नहीं है कि रबड़ ढकी
नहीं बन सकती। बन सकती है।
ओके बाकी
बाकी बाकी सर प्रैक्टिकल कैसे करेंगे पेड
वर्कशॉप में हां आप लोगों से मैंने एक चीज
पूछनी थी पेड वर्कशॉप कितने पैसों में
चाहिए
सोशल यह जो
सिमुलेशन के लिए
व्हाट नेक्स्ट नाउ सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का तो
मैंने अभी खत्म थोड़ी ना हुई है नो नो नो
नो नो नो नो नो एक्सटर्नल पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग में जो आपका मेन टॉपिक क्या है
वो क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स है और क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक्स का भी सब मेन टॉपिक क्या है
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
ठीक है सोशल इंजीनियरिंग और हमें अभी क्या
है सोशल इंजीनियर के फंडामेंटल्स कवर किए
हैं। नेक्स्ट क्लास में मैं एक आपको एक
मोस्ट फेमस बुक है। उसके एक साइकोलॉजिस्ट
हैं।
उसके बारे में कुछ एक उनकी जो सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग है एक ह्यूमन साइकोलॉजी के
बारे में वो आपको डिस्कस करने वाला हूं।
बिकॉज़ इट इज वेरी वेरीेंट टू नो कि सच में
ये चीजें काम करती है। आपको जिंदगी में
बहुत ज्यादा काम आएंगी भी। उसके बाद फिर
हम इसी में कंटिन्यू जाएंगे। अगर आप लोगों
को जानना है कि क्या-क्या चीजें हम पढ़ने
वाले हैं और क्या-क्या चीजें हम कवर करने
वाले हैं तो प्लीज विजिट क्लास 60 क्लास
नंबर 60 गो टू क्लास नंबर 60 एंड उसको
विजिट करो डीएचई की। वहां पर मैंने सबसे
पहले स्कोप डिफाइन मतलब ओवरव्यू दिया था
टॉपिक ओवरव्यू कि हम क्या-क्या कवर करने
वाले हैं आने वाली कुछ क्लासेस में।
किसी का कोई सवाल है फिर अभी?
कोई कुछ पूछना चाहता है, कोई सवाल है या
सेशन को एंड करें फिर बताओ जल्दी से।
ओके वर्कशॉप ₹300 में होना चाहिए। बाकी
लोग और
देखो पहली बार डिफॉन में
मैं
प्राइसिंग तय करने के लिए आप लोगों को भी
छोड़ रहा हूं।
आप लोग आप लोग डिसाइड करो कि कितने प्राइस
में वर्कशॉप चाहिए या वेबिनार चाहिए आपको।
ठीक है? कितने रुपए में चाहिए। अगर उसमें
भी नहीं आए ना आप लोग तो भैया फिर कुछ
नहीं हो सकता आप लोगों का।
ठीक है? ऐसा कोई नहीं होगा जो आप लोगों को
छोड़ दो।
बिल्कुल मैं तभी तो मैं बोल रहा हूं कि आप
लोग डिसाइड करो सारे मिलके
कितने में वर्कशॉप होनी चाहिए
क्योंकि एक चीज सोचना
वह वर्कशॉप होगी तो उसमें मेरे साइड से
बहुत खर्च होने वाला है आप जो वैल्यू ऐड
करोगे
ठीक है? मुझे उसमें कोई बेनिफिट नहीं होने
वाला होगा।
मतलब मेरा डेफोलिस का कोई बेनिफिट नहीं
होने वाला होगा। बट उसमें क्योंकि वो
प्रैक्टिकल सिमुलेशन करना सिर्फ उसके जो
भी चार्जेस लगेंगे वो मेरी जेब से लगेंगे।
बस वही मेन मोटो है।
ठीक है? सोच समझ के अगर आप सच में मेरे को
थोड़ी वैल्यू देना चाहते हो थोड़ा कि भाई
सचिन सर को कुछ ना कुछ बेनिफिट मिल जाए तो
वर्कशॉप के एक पेमेंट डिसाइड कर लो। तो आप
लोग ही बजट डिसाइड कर लो। सबको पता है। सब
लोग मैं एक काम करूंगा। आप लोगों को टाइम
दे दिया नेक्स्ट
वीक तक का। आप लोग सोच के बता दो। ठीक है?
ठीक। आप लोग सोच के बता दो कि आप लोग
कितने में
वो वेबिनार चाहते हो। प्रैक्टिकल लाइव
वेबिनार ऑन द फेसिंग कैंपेन या जो भी हम
बात करें सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का जिसमें आपको
प्रैक्टिकल नॉलेज आपको अच्छे से मिल जाए।
एक थोड़ा सा आपको रियल देखने को मिले।
चाहे वह हम 3 घंटे का लें, चाहे वह 6 घंटे
का लें। बस इतना ही उसमें सब कुछ थोड़ा
आपको आईडिया मिल जाए। इतना ही हो पाएगा।
ठीक है? तो वो आप लोग है नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट
सैटरडे और संडे को क्लासेस होंगे। अभी मैं
आपकी जो डीएचई की सीरीज है सैटरडे और संडे
को चलती है। तो उसमें आप खुद डिसाइड करो
कि कितने में होना चाहिए।
आप जब जितने रेट उसमें बताओगे उसमें से
कॉमन रेट निकाल लेंगे। ठीक है? एवरेज रेट
निकाल लेंगे। ओके
चलिए फिर आप लोगों का कोई डाउट नहीं है तो
थैंक यू बाय बाय गुड नाइट एवरीवन एंड
मिलते हैं फिर नेक्स्ट सैटरडे और संडे को
क्लासेस को कंटिन्यू करते हैं सेम क्लाइंट
अटैक्स वाली एक्शन पे टेस्टिंग की क्लासेस
को फिर से हम कंटिन्यू करते हैं। ठीक है?
चलिए फिर बाय-ब गुड नाइट एवरीवन एंड तब तक
के लिए आप लोगों को मैं यह बोलूंगा प्लीज
अगर क्लासेस थोड़ी सी और क्लेरिटी चाहिए
तो एक-एक बार सारी क्लासेस को और देख लो।
ठीक है? सारी क्लासेस को आप एक-एक बार देख
लो। आप ऐसे बातें कर रहे हो यार। अभी आप
एक रिचार्ज तो 500 600 में करवा लेते हो।
ठीक है? ₹100 के तो आप दो लोग मिलकर समोसे
खा जाते हो। एक जो जगत गुरु जी ₹50 बोल
रहे हो। ठीक है? ₹ ₹200 की तो कॉफी पी
जाते हो आप लोग बैठ के। और जब आप लोगों को
बजट की डिसाइड करने के लिए बोला गया तो आप
कुछ नहीं मैं कुछ नहीं बोलूंगा आप लोगों
को। बट आप लोगों की समझ है। देखते हैं आप
लोग क्या सोचते हो। मेरे लिए क्या वैल्यू
ऐड करोगे। पहली बार एज अ स्टूडेंट आप मेरे
को क्या देना चाह रहे हो। चलिए फिर बाय-ब
गुड नाइट एवरीवन सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट